AFTERNOON. I LIKE TO CALL TO
ORDER THE FIRST HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON UTILITY
AND ENERGY FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SESSION- WE'RE HERE FOR AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING TO DISCUSS
THE EXECUTION AND REGULATION OF
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS.
BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
FIRST WELCOME BACK THE
RETURNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND EXTEND AN EVEN
BIGGER WELCOME TO OUR NEW
MEMBER COMMITTEE MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REBECCA BAUER
KAHAN. WELCOME. I ALSO LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THE STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAMBERS WITH
US ARE OUR NEW CHIEF CONSULTANT
FLORSHEIM A- MELLOW LARA. SAYS
WITH THE COMMITTEE AS A SCIENCE
FELLOW OF SHE THEN WAS SNATCHED
UP BY SENATOR JERRY HILL AT THE
TIME. BECAME HIS CHIEF OF STAFF
AND IS NOW BACK BACK HOME SO WE
WELCOME YOU BACK. A REPUBLICAN
CONSULTANT GREGORY MELKONIAN.
WELCOME BACK. HI COMMITTEE
SECRETARY VANESSA VACCARO AND
JOINING US REMOTELY TODAY OUR
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF CHIEF
KELLY SMITH WHO WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH US THIS YEAR AND
OUR NEW SCIENCE FELLOW JANE
PARK. TO START WE HAVE SOME
HOUSEKEEPING TO GO OVER ARE WE
ARE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN AND WEARING MASKS
AT ALL TIMES DURING THE CHAMBER
IN THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL. WE
HAVE VERY LIMITED SPACE SO OUR
PANELISTS WILL BE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. WE ALSO HAVE THREE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI CORK AND SANTIAGO.
WE ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THE CALL IN DURING THE
PUBLIC COMMENT SEGMENT OF THIS
HEARING. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS AREA CODE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON THE TV
SCREEN. NOW IT'S SAFE TO SAY.
THAT WE ARE ALL FRUSTRATED BY
THE USE OF PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFFS BY OUR STATE'S
ELECTRIC UTILITIES. WE
UNDERSTAND WE DOUNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO USE THIS TOOL BUT IS
ABSOLUTELY MUST BE USED AS A
LAST RESORT. JUDICIOUSLY DURING
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS WHEN
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY TO ENSURE
THAT UTILITY EQUIPMENT WILL NOT
COME INTO CONTACT WITH
VEGETATION AND START THE FIRE.
AS WE'RE ALL TOO AWARE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO GET HIT
WITH THE RAVAGES. OF THE
CLIMATE CHANGE ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT. IT STRIKES IN MANY
AREAS. FOR THIS COMMITTEE WE
SEE HEAVY WINDS AND LOW
HUMIDITY ALONG WITH AN AGING
ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE CAUSING
TRAGIC FIRES WITH GREAT HARM TO
FAR TOO MANY COMMUNITIES. AFTER
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN FIRES IN
SAN DIEGO THE UTILITY WAS
AUTHORIZED BY THE CPUC TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF FIRES CAUSED
BY ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE BY
TEMPORARILY TURNING OFF POWER.
AND WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
ADDRESS WILDFIRE THREATS AND
UTILITIES IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
NEED TO HAVE PS PS EVENTS
CONTINUE AS A TOOL. BUT IT
WASN'T A MANDATE. BUT ITS
STRATEGIC USE IS CALLED INTO
QUESTION. WHEN WE SEE THE HUGE
JOB AND USE WHICH OCCURRED IN
TWENTY TWENTY. FROM TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WENTZ SDG AND
E. U. S. P. S. P. S. EVENTS FOR
THE FIRST TIME. TO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IT WAS USED THIRTY
THREE TIMES. BUT IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOR JUST ONE YEAR WE HAD
THIRTY THREE PS PS EVENTS. WHAT
HAPPENS. PS PS EVENTS WERE A
DISASTER IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. CUSTOMERS WERE
CONFUSED ANGRY AND PARTICULARLY
THOSE IN P. GINNY'S TERRITORY.
I THOUGHT THE UTILITIES LEARN
FROM THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
EVENTS. AND WHAT NOT TO DO. THE
CPUC N. O. YES ARE TO BE
COMMENDED FOR THE GREAT WORK
THEY DID IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
TIME PROTOCOLS AND WORK WITH
UTILITIES TO ENSURE THAT
IMPACTS ARE MITIGATED AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. AN ADULT REPORTS
INDICATE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS IN SOME PARTS OF
THE STATE PARTICULARLY IN PG&E
TERRITORIES HOWEVER WE WERE
ALARMED TO HEAR THAT EDISON
NEARLY DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
EVENTS THEY CALLED IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND HAD REPEATED
FAILURES TO FOLLOW PROTOCOLS AT
THE EXPENSE OF CUSTOMERS. AND
PUBLIC SAFETY. EVEN THOUGH THEY
REPEATEDLY ASSURED THE CPUC
PRESIDENT. THAT WE ARE GOING
TO. WE PLAN TO WE WANT TO BUT
IN THE MOMENT THEY DID NOT.
THIS RAISES THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE AGENCIES HAVE
SUFFICIENT ENFORCEMENT TOOLS
WHICH CAN BE USED IN REAL TIME
IF A UTILITY IS CALLING EVENTS
UNNECESSARILY OR FAILING TO
FOLLOW PROPER NOTIFICATION
PROTOCOLS FOR CUSTOMERS. PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR FIRST PANEL TO
DISCUSS THE REGULATION OF
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS.
PRESIDENT BADGER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR GIPSON DIRECTOR THOMAS
JACOBS AND DIRECTOR PALMER WE
WELCOME YOU. AND THE FLOOR IS
YOURS FOR THE REST. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR HOLDEN AND VICE CHAIR
PATTERSON AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AMERIGO BADGER AND I
SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WITH ME TODAY AS YOUSTATED. R. CPUC EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR RACHEL PETERSON AND
THE DIRECTOR OF OUR WILDFIRE
SAFETY DIVISION CAROLINE THOMAS
JACOBS BOTH OF WHOM WILL ALSO
PRESENT WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON.
LEE PALMER DIRECTOR OF OUR
SAFETY ENFORCEMENT DIVISION IS
ALSO HERE TO RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS AFTER OUR
PRESENTATION. RARELY HAS IT
BEEN MORE EVIDENT. THEN NOW
THAT RELIABLE ELECTRIC SERVICE
IS THE CENTRAL TO THE SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIANS.
IT IS AN IMPORTANT SERVICE IN
NORMAL TIMES. AND IT IS MORE
CRITICAL NOW WITH CALIFORNIA'S
LEARNING AND WORKING FROM HOME
DO TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
EPIDEMIC. PANDEMIC USING THE
ACCELERATION OF CLIMATE CHANGE
HAS BECAUSE OUR WELFARE SEASONS
TO START EARLIER AND END LATER.
TWENTY TWENTY INTO EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WAS A VERY LONG FIRE
SEASON AND CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCED A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF POWER SHUT OFFS BY
THEIR UTILITIES. UP UNTILMID
JANUARY THE MAJOR UTILITIES
WE'RE CONTINUING TO CALL POWER
SHUT OFF THE EVENTS. THE CPUC
HAS BEEN DRIVEN DRIVING. THE
UTILITIES TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
UTILITY BECAUSE WILDFIRES TO
BETTER PLANNING GRID HARDENING
AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
ANOTHER TOOL AVAILABLE TO THEM
IS TO PRO ACTIVELY SHUT POWER
OFF TO CUSTOMERS UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING DURING
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS. THESE
HAVE BECOME KNOWN AS POWER
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF OR PS PS
EVENTS. UNLIKE THE OTHER
MITIGATION STRATEGIES THESE
PROACTIVE POWER SHUT OFFS HAVE
VERY REAL AND DIRECT IMPACTS TO
CUSTOMERS. EVERY TIME UTILITIES
SHUTS OFF POWER IT IS TRADING
OFF THE SAFETY AND IMMEDIATE
WELL BEING OF ITS CUSTOMERS TO
MITIGATE RISK OF IGNITED A
WILDFIRE. THIS TRADE OFF IS Y.
P. S. B. S. OF THIS MUST BE A
MEASURE OF LAST RESORT. FOR
MANY LOSS OF POWER MEANS LOSS
OF INCOME LOSS OF A DAY OR MORE
OF LEARNING. A FEAR AND
UNCERTAINTY FOR THOSE WHO RELY
ON POWER TO SUSTAIN LIFE
SUPPORTING MEDICAL DEVICES. AT
RISK IN A P. S. P. S. OF THAT
OUR PEOPLE'S LIVES AND PEOPLE'S
LIVELIHOODS. THESE RISK MUST
CONTINUALLY UNDERSTOOD THESE
REST MUST BE CONTINUALLY
UNDERSCORED. WHEN THE TWO OF
THESE WERE BEFORE THE
COMMISSION LAST AUGUST TO
PRESENT ON THEIR PREPAREDNESS
TO THE TO EXECUTE B. S. B. AS
VETS IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
EMPHASIZE THAT THE EFFECTS ON
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE NOT
THEORETICAL BUT VERY REAL. WE
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THEY WOULD
BE JUDGED BY OUTCOMES. NOT BY
PLANTS. WHEN LOOKING AT
OUTCOMES OF THIS PAST YEAR'S PS
PS EVENTS WE CONTINUE TO SEE
THE NEED FOR IMPROVEMENT ACROSS
ALL UTILITIES. AS WE WILL
REMEMBER P. GENIES POOR
EXECUTION OF PS PS IN THE FALL
OF TWENTY NINETEEN HIGHLIGHTED
THE NEED TO UPDATE OUR PS PS
GUIDELINES AND UTILIZE THE
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLAN
PROCESS TO STEER THE UTILITIES
TOWARDS IMPROVING THEIR
PERFORMANCE AND LESSENING THE
SCOPE. MAGNITUDE AND FREQUENCY
OF PS PS EVENTS. FOUR PG&E WE
APPEAR TO SEE IMPROVEMENTS AS
AS CHAIR YOU STATED EARLIER ON
A FEW FRONTS OVERALL REDUCTION
IN SCOPE AND SCALE COMPARED TO
TWENTY NINETEEN IMPROVE
PLANNING OF COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS AS WELL AS IMPROVED
FORECASTING. HOWEVER
INFORMATION SHARING WITH STATE
LOCAL AGENCIES AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS NEEDS TO BE
ENHANCED. WE EXPECT GREATER
EXPANSION. IN DEPLOYMENT OF ITS
BATTERY BACKUP PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY FOR THE MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMERS AND ITS
NOTIFICATION PROTOCOLS ALSO
REQUIRE IMPROVEMENTS.
ESPECIALLY IN ELIMINATING
INSTANCES WHEN IMPACTED
CUSTOMERS ARE NOT NOTICED OR
WHAT WE REFER TO AS NO NOTICE
D. INTERNALIZATION. FOUR ESTY
GENIE WE ALSO SEE IMPROVED
PLANNING OF ITS COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS BUT THEY TO
REQUIRE IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
AREAS OF INFORMATION SHARING
WITH STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES.
GREATER DEPLOYMENT IN ITS
BATTERY BACKUP PROGRAM AGAIN
PARTICULARLY FOR THE MEDICAL
BASED LIKE CUSTOMERS AND
ELIMINATING ALSO THE NO NOTICE
D. ENERGY STATION. NOW WITH
RESPECT TO EDISON'S PS PS
EVENTS THIS YEAR THIS PAST YEAR
ITS PERFORMANCE HAS REQUIRED
SPECIAL ATTENTION AND HAS BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF WHO TO PUBLIC
MEETINGS AT THE COMMISSION.
SAYS THE START OF THIS CALENDAR
YEAR. THERE ARE MANY AREAS
WHERE I BELIEVE EDISON DID NOT
MEASURE UP TO THE STANDARDS OF
ITS CUSTOMERS WHICH IT
CUSTOMERS DESERVE. EDICION
INITIATED SIXTEEN PS PS EVENTS
BETWEEN MAY AND DECEMBER LAST
YEAR. THE MAJORITY OF THE
EVENTS WERE IN NOVEMBER AND
DECEMBER INCLUDING TWO DURING
THE MAJOR HOLIDAYS. AMONG THE
VARIOUS PROBLEMS WE OBSERVE FOR
ISSUES WITH THE LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY AROUND EVER SINCE
PS PS DECISION MAKING PROCESS
IN ADEQUATE NOTIFICATION TO
IMPACTED CUSTOMERS POOR
COORDINATION AND COMMUNICATION
WITH STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. SHORTCOMINGS IN
IDENTIFYING AND NOTIFYING
MEDICAL BASELINE AND ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS CUSTOMERS AND
DEFICIENT PS PS POST EVENT
REPORTING TO THE COMMISSION. IN
ADDITION WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH THE PACE
AT WHICH EDISON HAS BEEN
DEPLOYING BACKUP POWER TO HELP
VULNERABLE CUSTOMERS COPE WITH
PS PS CHáVEZ. REGARDING
EDISON'S NOTIFICATION
SHORTCOMINGS. ONLY 20% OF THE
CUSTOMERS IT GAVE ADVANCE
NOTICES TO THIS PAST FIRE
SEASON WERE AFFECTED BY A P. S.
P. S. OF AT. BUT IT IS DESIRED
TO HAVE AS FEW CUSTOMERS DE
ENERGIZED AS POSSIBLE THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THIS
PLANNING APPROACH IF YOU'RE
CONSISTENTLY PUTTING LARGE
NUMBERS OF CUSTOMERS ON NOTICE
AND THEN NOTHING HAPPENS. THERE
WERE ALSO TOO MANY INSTANCES
THAT THERE WERE NO NOTICE D.
ENERGY STATIONS. FORECASTING
AND COMMUNICATIONS MUST IMPROVE.
LAST YEAR THE CPUC HAD TO
ENHANCE ITS OVERSIGHT OF P.
GENIES CORRECTIVE ACTIONS GOING
INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY FIRE
SEASON. WE'RE DOING THIS NOW
WITH EDISON THIS YEAR TO ENSURE
THEY LIVE UP TO THEIR
COMMITMENTS UNDER THEIR
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN. IN
ADDITION TO THE EDSON FOCUSED
PUBLIC MEETINGS WE HAVE HAD
THIS YEAR WE WILL ALSO HOST A
PUBLIC WORKSHOP THIS MONTH. TO
HEAR FROM ALL UTILITIES AND
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES ON LESSONS
LEARNED FROM TWENTY TWENTY.
THESE LESSONS WILL INFORM AND
ANOTHER ROUND OF UPDATING OF
OUR PS PS GUIDELINES WHICH WEEK
COMMENCED. ON FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HOLD PUBLIC MEETINGS AS WE
ENTER THE CRITICAL MONTHS OF
THE WELFARE SEASON TO ASSESS
THE UTILITIES PREPAREDNESS. IF
REQUIRED WE WILL UTILIZE OUR
EXPANSIVE ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
OVER THE UTILITIES TO DELIVER
THE TYPE OF BEHAVIOR CUSTOMERS
DESERVE AND EXPECT FROM
PROVIDERS OF AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICE. IN FACT AS A RESULT OF
THE UTILITIES POOR EXECUTION OF
PS PS EVENTS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THE CVC OPENED UP A FORMAL
INVESTIGATION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER UTILITIES PRIORITIZE
SAFETY AND COMPLY WITH THE
COMMISSION'S P. USE P. S. P. S.
REGULATIONS AND REQUIREMENTS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS PARTICIPATING IN
THIS INVESTIGATION AND A FORMER
FORMAL DECISION IS FORTHCOMING.
LASTLY I WANT TO RE ITERATE THE
C. P. UC'S COMMITMENT TO
DRIVING UTILITIES TOWARDS ZERO
NEED. AND THE USE OF PS PS THE
LOSS OF POWER CAUSES MAJOR
DISRUPTIONS TO HOUSEHOLDS
BUSINESSES MEDICAL FACILITIES
COMMUNICATION CARRIERS. AND
OTHER CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S STRANGE THE STATE AND
LOCAL EMERGENCY AND PUBLIC
SAFETY PERSONNEL AS THEY WORK
TO ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY ON
OTHER. FRONTS THE PUBLIC
DESERVES BETTER AND WE ARE
WORKING TO ENSURE THEY ARE
BETTER SERVED BY THE UTILITIES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR VICE
CHAIR I WILL NOW ASK EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR PETERSON TO PROVIDE-
HER PRESENTATION FOR YOU. THANK
YOU PRESIDENT PATTERNED- THANK
YOU TERRY HOLDEN VICE CHAIR AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY MY
PURPOSE IS TO TELL YOU ABOUT
THE CLOSED END URGENT
ENGAGEMENT THAT DIRECTOR PALMER
DIRECTOR THOMAS JACOBS AND I
HAD WITH THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO IMPROVE
THEIR EXECUTION OF PS PS EVENTS.
OUR ENGAGEMENT IS DRIVEN BY
CONTINUALLY UNDERSCORING THE
RISKS TO PUBLIC SAFETY THAT PS
PS EVENTS BRING AS PRESIDENT
BADGER SAID. THE FACT
REGULATORY EXPECTATIONS AND
RULES THAT THEY'VE UTILITIES
ARE REQUIRED TO BE AS THE
OPERATORS OF THEIR SYSTEM. AND
LAST TO DRIVE THE UTILITIES
TOWARD ENTIRELY ELIMINATING
THEIR USE OF DNA TECHNICIAN AS
A WILDFIRE RISK MITIGATION TOOL.
WE PARTNER CLOSELY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT CALIFORNICA OH
YES TO HOLD THE UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE. EVERY MONTH FROM
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONWARD
WE HELD LEADERSHIP LEVEL
MEETINGS THAT PRESIDENT VOUCHER
CHIEF THOMAS PORTER AND
DIRECTOR MARK JEWELERS YUJI AND
THEIR DELEGATES ATTENDED. ALONG
WITH LEADERSHIP FROM THE THREE
LARGE ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO
DISCUSS WILDFIRE AND PS PS
PREPARATION. WE CONTINUE THOSE
MONTHLY MEETINGS AND CHIEF
PORTER AND DIRECTOR JEWELERS
YOU G. JUST YESTERDAY JOIN
PRESIDENT AFTER TO HEAR FROM
THE UTILITIES ABOUT THEIR
PREPARATION FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SEASON. AT THE
SENIOR STAFF LEVEL DIRECTOR
PALMER DIRECTOR THOMAS JACOBS
AND I. ALONG WITH NUMEROUS
MEMBERS OF OUR TEAMS JOINT
CALLOW YES AND THE UTILITIES
FOR MONTHLY OPERATIONAL
MEETINGS ALSO THROUGHOUT TWENTY
TWENTY. AT THOSE MEETINGS WE
FOCUS ON THE UTILITIES READY
NICE TO SUBMIT NOTIFICATION
FORMS AS REQUIRED BY CARILLO
YES AND ENSURE THAT THEIR DATA
AND MAPS WERE READY TO BE
PROVIDED TO EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS AMONG OTHER
OPERATIONAL AND DISEASE. NOW I
WANT TO TURN MORE SPECIFICALLY
TO OUR ENGAGEMENT WITH PG&E. WE
CONCENTRATED THE MOST ATTENTION
ON P. JEANNIE LAST YEAR BECAUSE
THEIR EXECUTION HAS BEEN SO
POOR IN TWENTY NINETEEN. AND
BECAUSE THE COMPANY WAS STILL
IN BANKRUPTCY AT THAT TIME.
PRESENT ABOUT YOUR ISSUED A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN IN LATE
TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH DIRECTOR
PALMER AND DIRECTOR THOMAS
JACOBS AND I USED AS THE BASIS
FOR WEEKLY DETAILED BRIEFINGS
ON THEIR PROGRESS. WE REQUIRED
YOU DO NEED TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE
OF MILESTONE ACHIEVEMENTS ON
EVERY ELEMENT OF PS PS
PREPARATION. CRUCIALLY WE
REQUIRE NUMEROUS IMPROVEMENTS
TO BE COMPLETED BEFORE
SEPTEMBER FIRST TO ENSURE THAT
THEY WERE IN PLACE BEFORE THE
MOST INTENSE PART OF THE WILD
WIND AND PSPO SEASON. ON THE
CUSTOMER FRONT FOR EXAMPLE WE
TRACKED THEIR PROGRESS IN
UNDERSTANDING THEIR MEDICAL
BASELINE AND CRITICAL CARE
CUSTOMERS NEEDS AND LOCATIONS
AND HOW TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THEM. WE TRACKED THEIR
PREPARATION OF COMMUNICATION
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS AND
ESTABLISH HOW THEY WERE
ESTABLISHING STRONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH CITY COUNTY
AND TRIBAL EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS. AND THEIR TRAINING
OF A MURDER THEIR OWN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PERSONNEL ALL WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC THAT WE WERE ALL
LIVING THROUGH. ON THE
TECHNOLOGY FRONT WE MONITORED
IMPROVEMENTS TO THEIR WEBSITE
AND EFFORT THAT WE INVOLVED THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY IN AS WELL. THIS
STEPPING UP THEIR CUSTOMER CALL
CENTER AND THEIR GIS SYSTEMS
THAT WOULD SHOW THE MAP AND
SCOPE OF IT. PS PS OUTAGE AS
WELL AS ALL OF THEIR TOOLS TO
MONITOR WEATHER CONDITIONS AND
FORECAST THE NEED AND SCOPE OF
THE PS PFE THAT'S- AS FOR THE
ELECTRIC GRIN. WE MONITORED P.
GENIES DEPLOYMENT OF SECTIONALS
VISION DEVICES BACK UP
GENERATION AND OTHER WAYS OF
PROTECTING GROUPS OF CUSTOMERS
FROM LOSING ELECTRICITY. WHEN
IT CAME TO P. GENIES EXECUTION
IN TWENTY TWENTY I BELIEVE THAT
PRESIDENT BADGERS CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN PLUS ARE CLOSE
ENGAGEMENT HAD THE EFFECT OF
IMPROVING THE UTILITIES
EXECUTION LAST YEAR. NOW
TURNING TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON. USED TO THE SAME
ENGAGEMENT APPROACH FOR EDISON
IN PARTICULAR IN THE SUMMER
BRIEFINGS ON THEIR
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR MEDICAL
BASELINE AND CRITICAL CARE
CUSTOMERS. THEIR PREPAREDNESS
TO PROVIDE MAPS AND INFORMATION
ABOUT EVENTS TO CAROL- YEAH AND
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS. AND THEIR
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS. WE
MONITOR TABLE TOP EXERCISES
ALONG WITH OUR COLLEAGUES THE
CALLOW YES AND PROVIDED
SPECIFIC FEEDBACK. EDISON
NEARLY CALLED THE S. P. S.
EVENTS INVADE MAY AND JUNE LAST
YEAR AND WE HELD IT AFTER
ACTION DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM
INCLUDING CHIEF TOM PORTER TO
DRIVE HOME THE POINT THAT THEIR
WEATHER AND WILDFIRE RISK
CONDITIONS FORECASTING TOOLS
NEEDED IMPROVEMENT. IN AUGUST
WE REQUIRED ADDISON AND THE
OTHER UTILITIES TO RUN A TEST
NOTIFICATION TO THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS CARRIERS AND WE
OBSERVE TO PRESS ALT THEY GAVE
US CONCERNED. WE DIRECTLY
INFORMED ADDISON OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT COMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES EXPERIENCE WITH THOSE
NOTIFICATIONS. DURING THE FALL
AND EARLY WINTER PRESIDENT
BADGERING THE COMMISSIONERS AND
OUR PARTNERS AT CALLAWAY F. IN
CALIFORNIA- ALL GREW
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT
EDISON'S EXECUTION. AS
PRESIDENT BADGER NOTED TO YOU.
EDISON OVER NOTIFIED IN SOME
CASES AND FAILED TO NOTIFY AND
OTHERS QUITE EGREGIOUSLY ON
THANKSGIVING DAY. THERE WERE
EVENTS BACK TO BACK. ALI
EXPERIENCE A PARTICULARLY
SEVERE SEASON WITH NINE P. S.
P. S. EVENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY
AND ONE IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE RESPONDED
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THEIR LAST
EVENT WHICH LASTED FROM JANUARY
TWELFTH TO JANUARY TWENTY FIRST.
PRESIDENT BASSAR ISSUED A
PUBLIC LETTER TO EDISON ON
JANUARY NINETEENTH EXPRESSING
HER DEEP CONCERNS WITH THEIR
EXECUTION. AS WITH PG&E AT THE
END OF TWENTY NINETEEN THE
LETTER LAID OUT FIVE AREAS OF
CONCERN. AND SET OUT CORRECTIVE
ACTION EXPECTATIONS. THE AREAS
ARE OF THE TRANSPARENCY OF
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS
HOW THEY EXECUTE THEIR
NOTIFICATIONS COMMUNICATING AND
WORKING WELL WITH STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
UNDERSTANDING THEIR MEDICAL
BASELINE AND ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS CUSTOMERS AND
THE QUALITY OF THEIR PS PS POST
EVENT REPORTING. ON JANUARY
TWENTY SIXTH WE HELD A PUBLIC
MEETING TO DISCUSS THE LETTER
LED BY PRESIDENT BAXTER AND THE
CPUC COMMISSIONERS. AND WITH
THE PARTICIPATION OF CHAR
HOLDEN CALIFORNIA CHIEF PORTER
CALORIE OR YES DIRECTOR TO THE
G. G. CONGRESSMAN MIKE GARCIA
SENATOR BEN HUESO AND SENATOR
HENRY STERN. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SAYS THAT BY A DATA. OR COUNTY
SAN DONALD WAGNER AND SEVERAL
ELECTED FROM SIMI VALLEY AND
ACTON TOWN. THE LEADERS
DIRECTLY QUESTION ABSENT ON
THEIR EXECUTION AND THE
COMPANY'S EXECUTIVES ALSO HEARD
TWO HOURS OF PUBLIC COMMENT
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF PS PS ON
PEOPLE'S DAILY LIVES. ON
FEBRUARY TWELFTH AS REQUIRED BY
US EDISON SUBMITTED THEIR
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN. AND IN
THE SAME WAY THAT W REQUIRE
DETAILED BRIEFINGS FROM PG&E
AND TWENTY TWENTY WE THINK ON
THE SAME DETAILED BRIEFINGS ON
MILESTONES AND IMPROVEMENTS
WITH ADDISON. AS PRESIDENT
BADGER NOTED JUST THIS PAST
MONDAY WE ALSO HOLD A PUBLIC
DISCUSSION OF THE SAME
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN SO THAT
THE PUBLIC COULD HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM AND FROM THE COMPANY. IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M NOT
GOING TO TOUCH ON DETAILS ARE
ENGAGEMENT WITH S. U. G. A. B.
BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ON THAT IF REQUESTED.
I WANT TO ADDRESS ENFORCEMENT
BRIEFLY. WE HAVE TO OPEN FORMAL
ENFORCEMENT PROCEEDINGS GOING
ON RIGHT NOW. WHICH USE THE
EXTENT OF OUR ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS- RELATED TO THAT ALL THE
UTILITIES PERFORMANCE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. NOW SINCE THE LAST PS
PS EVENT CONCLUDED ON JANUARY
TWENTY FIRST OUR SAFETY
IMPORTANT ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
UNDER DIRECTOR PALMER IS
CONDUCTING COMPLIANCE REVIEW OF
ALL THIRTY THREE. PS PS POST
EVENT REPORTS. FOR EACH EVENT
WE REQUIRE THE UTILITIES TO
REPORT ON APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS. OF THE
RELATED TO THEIR EXECUTION THAT
INCLUDES THEIR FORECASTING OF
WEATHER AND RISK CONDITIONS
DETAILS OF THEIR NOTIFICATION
THE TOTAL NUMBERS AND
CATEGORIES OF IMPACTED
CUSTOMERS. THE STAND UP AN
OPERATION OF COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS- AND COMMUNICATION WITH
STATE AND LOCAL AND TRIBAL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. THESE ARE
COMPLEX EVENTS AND WE DO NEED
TO EVALUATE MULTIPLE ASPECTS OF
EACH ONE. WELL WE'RE CONDUCTING
OUR COMPLIANCE REVIEW WE ARE
CONSIDERING APPROPRIATE
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS SUCH AS
LARGER FORMAL INVESTIGATIONS
POTENTIAL NOTICES OF VIOLATIONS
AND PROPOSAL'S REMEDIES OR
FINANCIAL PENALTIES TO THE
COMMISSION. WE'VE NOT YET
ESTABLISHED A DELEGATED STAFF
CITATION PROGRAM FOR THE
GUIDELINES THE PS PS GUIDELINES
THAT'S WHY I C. D. WOULD NEED
TO PROPOSE REMEDIES OR
PENALTIES TO THE COMMISSION FOR
APPROVAL. AFTER IT COMPLETES
ITS COMPLIANCE REVIEW. AND ON
THAT NOTE WE DO HAVE BROAD
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY OVER THE-
ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND A WIDE
RANGE OF ENFORCEMENT TOOLS AT
OUR DISPOSAL AND WE SEEK TO USE
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE TO THE SITUATION.
HERE ARE INTERESTED IN THE
STATE EXECUTION OF PS PS OF
THEM. SO. TO THAT END I HOPE
I'VE PROVIDED YOU WITH A SENSE
OF OUR CLOSE AND BURGEONING
GAUGE MA'AM WITH UTILITIES IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND HOW THAT
ENGAGEMENT IS CONTINUING. AS I
TURNED TO DIRECTOR CAROLINE
THOMAS JACOBS WHO RUNS OUR
WILDFIRE SAFETY DIVISION.
SHE'LL TALK ABOUT P. S. P. S.
AS A RISK MITIGATION STRATEGY
IN THE WILD PER MEDICATION
PLANS. AND I WANT TO KNOW THAT
THE CPUC AS CLOSELY AS WE ARE
ENGAGING NOW WITH THE UTILITIES
IS NOT RESTING ON ANY
ASSUMPTION. THAT DE ENERGIZE
ASIAN IS PERMANENTLY WITH US IN
CALIFORNIA IN FACT WE'RE
DRIVING TO ELIMINATE THIS RISK
STRATEGY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT COULD RECORD PETERSON GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE HOLDEN VICE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY AS
MENTIONED ON THE RECORD THE
RELATIVELY NEW WILDFIRE SAFETY
DIVISION ESTABLISHED IN JANUARY
LAST YEAR OUR PRIMARY MISSION
IS OVERSIGHT OF THE UTILITY'S
EFFORTS TO REDUCE THEIR
WILDFIRE RISK THE MAIN VEHICLE
THROUGH WHICH WE DO THAT IS
THERE WATER MITIGATION PLANS.
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY PLANTS
THE COMMISSION ADOPTED
COMPREHENSIVE NEW GUIDELINES
THAT REQUIRED THE UTILITIES TO
EXPLAIN HOW THEY UNDERSTAND AND
ADDRESS THEIR WILDFIRE RISK
REQUIRED SUBMISSION OF NEW
PERFORMANCE METRICS SO WE COULD
COMPARE UTILITIES AND TRACK
PROGRESS OVER TIME AND ADOPTED
A NEW MATURITY MODEL TO MONITOR
GROWTH OF KEY CAPABILITIES. OUR
INTENT WITH THE TWO GUARD WAS
TO ESTABLISH A BASELINE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE UTILITIES
WILDFIRE MITIGATION
CAPABILITIES. REQUIRING AT THE
PLANS TO HAVE THE UTILITIES
EXPLAINER UNDERSTANDING OF
THEIR RISK. DESCRIBE HOW TO
STRATEGIES REDUCE THAT RISK AND
DRIVE CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT.
WE INCORPORATED INTO THE PLANT
INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY
GUIDELINES AND MOST RELEVANT TO
OUR DISCUSSION TODAY A
REQUIREMENT FOR THE UTILITIES
TO EXPLAIN THEIR USE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF AS A
WILDFIRE MITIGATION STRATEGY.
HERE I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
DISTINCTION ON THE DIVISION
ROLE ON PS PS AND THE
COMMISSION. WITHIN THE WILD
PART OF EDUCATION PLANS WE
ADDRESS PS PS AT THE
PROGRAMMATIC LEVEL WELL THE
COMMISSION'S PF PF SPECIFIC
GUIDELINES AND REGULATIONS
PROVIDE DIRECTION ON THE
TACTFUL USE OF IT. WE LOOK AT
PS PS AS ONE OF THE UTILITIES
MANY WILDFIRE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES. WE RECOGNIZE
HOWEVER THAT THAT PS PS IS
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER WELFARE
MITIGATION STRATEGIES DUE TO
ITS ASSOCIATED COSTS AND
IMPACTS SUCH AS THE IMPACT ON
AT RISK CUSTOMERS PUBLIC SAFETY
PROVIDERS IN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. WITHIN THE
DIVISION WE ALSO TREAT PFAS NOT
JUST AS A STRATEGY BUT A
STRATEGY THAT HAS ITS OWN
INHERENT RISK. DUE TO THOSE
CONSEQUENCES. OUR APPROACH THAT
IS THAT PS PS WHEN CONSIDERED
ALONGSIDE INVESTMENT IN OTHER
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
HARDENING GREAT REDESIGN.
SHOULD BE REDUCED IN SCOPE
DURATION AND FREQUENCY OVER
TIME. THAT MEANS THE PS PS
SHOULD BE A WATER MITIGATION
STRATEGY THAT EVENTUALLY IS NO
LONGER NEEDED. LAST YEAR
THROUGH THE NEW PERFORMANCE
METRICS WE REQUIRE WE REQUIRE
THE UTILITIES TO SUBMIT
HISTORICAL PS PS METRICS THAT
SUMMARIZE THE ANNUAL PS PS
IMPACT SUCH AS THE NUMBER OF
EVENTS. PUT UP A TOTAL CUSTOMER
OUTAGE HOURS AND THE IMPACTS TO
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
NOW WE INCLUDE NOW WE REQUIRE.
ON THOSE METRICS THOSE METRICS
PROVIDES A BASELINE UPON WHICH
TO PRINT COMPARE PROGRESS OVER
YEAR. ON FEBRUARY FIFTH THE
LARGE UTILITIES PG&E SAN DIEGO
AND EDISON SUBMITTED THEIR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHILE FOR
MITIGATION PLAN UPDATES.
THERE'S A MISSION INCLUDED
THEIR PF PF PERFORMANCE METRICS
FOR TWENTY TWENTY. SO NOW FOR
THE FIRST TIME WE CAN MEASURE
PROGRESS YEAR OVER YEAR. SINCE
WE ARE ACTIVELY IN OUR
EVALUATION OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE PLANNED I WILL NOT SPEAK TO
OUR ONGOING ASSESSMENT OF THOSE
PLANS. I WILL HOWEVER MENTION A
FEW KEY FACTS FROM THEIR
SUBMISSIONS THAT OUR PUBLIC AND
AVAILABLE TO ALL. FURTHER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DATA
SUBMISSIONS WELL THE NUMBER OF
P. S. P. S. EVENTS ONE UP
ACROSS THE STATE. THE OVERALL
NUMBER OF CATS CUSTOMER OUTAGE
HOURS DUE TO PS PS DECREASED.
SPECIFICALLY PG&E AND EDISON
REDUCED OUTAGE HOURS. PG&E
DROPPED FROM NINETY POINT SEVEN
MILLION CUSTOMER OUTAGE HOURS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWO POINT THREE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY. EDISON DROPPED
FROM FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
HOW DID HOURS TO FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION OUT OF DOLLARS
WEALTHY DIEGO ACTUALLY DOUBLE
THERE'S FROM WHAT ONE POINT
THREE MILLION OUT OF OURS IN
NINETEEN TO TWO POINT SIX. IN
TWENTY TWENTY. THIS IS NOT
HOWEVER ADDRESS THE VERY REAL
ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN MENTIONED A
FEW TIMES ALREADY THIS EVENING
OR THIS AFTERNOON. IN WE CAN
EVENT THIS CALL BUT NO
DEACTIVATION HAPPENED. A
POTENTIAL DEREGULATION STILL
CARRIES WITH IT RISK FOR
COMMUNITIES PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERS AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. GIVEN THAT RISK
IN ADDITION TO SUBMITTING THEIR
TWENTY TWENTY PFF'S METRICS. IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE PLANS WE
NOW REQUIRE THE UTILITIES TO
DESCRIBE THEIR VISION. FOR THE
NECESSITY OF PS PS OVER TIME.
AND XPLAIN THEIR PLANS TO
REDUCE SCALE SCOPE AND
IMPORTANTLY FREQUENCY OF PS PS
GOING INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SEASON. AND AGAIN I WILL BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO OUR ONGOING
ASSESSMENT OF THOSE COMMITMENTS
I'M SURE THE UTILITIES WILL
SPEAK TO THEM IN THEIR REMARKS
I DO HOWEVER WANT TO CALL IT A
FEW ELEMENTS. TO SHOW HOW WE
ARE USING THE PLAN IS TO MAKE
THE UTILITIES DESCRIBED THEIR
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE PFAS
OF SEASONS AND EXPLAIN THEIR
EXPECTATIONS. FOR HOW THEIR P.
S. P. S. PROGRAM WILL EVOLVE
OVER THE COMING YEARS. FOR
EXAMPLE. HE ASKED ABOUT PG&E
STATE SENATE'S PICK IT IS
TAKING ACTION TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF PS PS. BUT LIKE THE
FUTURE UNCERTAINTY LIMITS ITS
ABILITY TO SET TARGETS. TO
REDUCE SCOPE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SPECIFICALLY PG&E PROJECT
AN INCREASE OF EIGHT MILLION
CUSTOMER OUTAGE HOURS IN PS PS
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SEASON. ALL THREE UTILITIES
PROJECT MORE FIRE WEATHER
CONDITIONS IN THE COMING YEARS
BUT ONLY P. JEANNIE PRODUCTION
HIGHER USE OF PS PS. PG&E THE
INCREASED PRODUCTION IS
ATTRIBUTED TO UNCERTAINTY
SURROUNDING THEIR FEDERAL
PROBATION AND CURRENT PROPOSED
CONDITIONS THAT COULD IMPACT P.
GENIES- IMPLEMENTATION OF PS PS.
EDISON EXPECTS TO REDUCE PF PF
CUSTOMER OUTAGE HOURS BY THIRTY
TO FORTY PERCENT. FROM FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION THIS PAST
SEASON TO TWO POINT SIX MILLION
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND SAN
DIEGO EXPECTS APPROXIMATELY A
40% DECREASE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FROM TWO POINT SIX MILLION
TO ONE POINT SIX NINE. WITH THE
CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT OF THE
DIVISIONS COMPLIANCE PROGRAMS
BEGINNING THIS YEAR WE ALSO NOW
REQUIRE THE UTILITIES TO
PROVIDE QUARTERLY PERFORMANCE
DATA. SO WE CAN TRACK PROGRESS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. INCLUDING
PROGRESS ON INITIATIVES SUCH AS
SEXUALIZING AND WEATHER
FORECASTING. FREQUENCY SCOPE
AND DURATION EVENTS IN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CUSTOMERS-IMPACTED. THESE DATA WILL BE
USED TO TRACK PROGRESS ON THAT
THE UTILITIES IMPLEMENTATION TO
ASSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR
ANNUAL COMMITMENT. YOU SHOULD
TELL THE MAKES AND THE
MITIGATION PLAN. TO REDUCE THE
SCOPE. DURATION AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FREQUENCY OF PS PS
AS A MITIGATION STRATEGY. TO
CLOSE ALL REITERATE PS PS IS
INCLUDED IN THE PLANS AT A
PROGRAMMATIC LEVEL AN ACT THAT
LEVEL WE'RE AFFECTING IT'S USED
AS BOTH A MITIGATION STRATEGY.
AS WELL S A RISK FACTOR UNTO
ITSELF DO THE SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES IT HAS ON OUR
COMMUNITIES. OUR EVALUATION OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE PLANTS IS
SCHEDULED TO BE COMPLETED BY
THE GIRLS EARLY SUMMER. AND
WILL INCLUDE AN ASSESSMENT OF
THE UTILITIES PLANNED FOR
FUTURE USE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
THE- DETAIL OF YOUR
PRESENTATION AND- GETTING US A
FOCUSED ON THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT AS A REGULATORY BODY
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO. TO MOVE
OUT ON SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY- NEXT I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR SECOND PANEL TO
DISCUSS THE EXECUTION. OF
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS.
AND SO WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME
PHIL HARRINGTON. A SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. JILL
ANDERSON SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
OF CUSTOMER SERVICE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. CEMEX
SCIENCE. A SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT CHIEF RISK OFFICER
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC. AND
JOHN JENKINS VICE PRESIDENT
ELECTRIC SYSTEM OPERATIONS SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC- IF YOU GO
IN THE ORDER IN WHICH YOU WERE
CALLED THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED SO WILL WELCOME
FIRST- PHIL HARRINGTON. WELCOME
BACK THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING- ACTUALLY THIS GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW CHARLTON AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M
PHIL HARRINGTON SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON- AS- THE
CHAIR NOTED MY COLLEAGUE JOE
ANDERSON. A SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF CUSTOMER SERVICE
WILL ALSO JOIN YOU PRESENTED TO
YOU TODAY. WE'VE ALSO PROVIDED
SOME BACKUP MATERIAL- FOR YOUR
REFERENCE I WILL NOT BE-
REPORTED A SLIGHT SO AS I GO TO
MY CONVERSATION HERE. BOB LET
ME START BY SAYING WHAT YOU ALL
KNOW TOO WELL AND THAT'S THE
TWENTY TWENTY WAS A YEAR OF
UNIMAGINABLE. TRAGEDY FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS. FIVE SIX LARGE
WHILE FOR ARE HAVE A TWENTY. OF
THESE FIRES BURNED MORE THAN
POINT TWO EIGHT OF THE STATE IN
CLAIMS. THREE LIVES. THE NUMBER
MAGNITUDE OF LAST YEAR'S
WILDFIRES ILLUSTRATE THE NATURE
AND EXTENT OF THE FIRE THREAT
WE'RE FACING. HOUSTON WEATHER
CONDITIONS ALONG WITH ABUNDANT
DRY FUELS. UNTIL A FEW WEEKS
AGO WITH A VERY LIGHT- ANSETT
RAINS RAINFALL TOTALS IN
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RUN OUR SERVICE TERRITORY.
ABOUT 5275% BELOW AVERAGE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE SAW 70% MORE
RED FLAG WARNING DAY SEVEN
TWENTY NINETY. OF THOSE
CONDITIONS COMBINED WITH
MULTIPLE WAYS OF DANGEROUS
SANTA ANA WINDS TRIGGERED
THRESHOLDS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
PARRIS SHUTTLES FAR MORE FAR
MORE THAN ANY OF US WOULD WANT.
BUT EVEN UNDER THE SEVERE
CIRCUMSTANCES WE DO SEE PROOF
THAT OUR ACCELERATOR WILDFIRE
MITIGATION WORK IS REDUCING THE
SCALE CUSTOMER IMPACT OF THESE
B. S. B. S. OFFENSE. FOR
INSTANCE. IN 202046% OF THE
CIRCUS DE ENERGIZED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN DID NOT EXPERIENCE A
P. S. P. S. ABOUT. THE LARGEST
AMOUNT OF TWENTY TWENTY
IMPACTED 25% OF YOUR CUSTOMERS
AND THE LARGEST ONE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. THERE IS MUCH MORE TO
DO AS IT BECOME CLEAR. TRAMLINE
HERE IS MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. THIS IS POSSIBLE IN
PART BECAUSE OUR ABILITY TO
SEGMENT CIRCUITS AND A RANGE OF
CUSTOMERS CARD BY ALTERNATIVE
ONES. WE DO THIS BASED ON
SWITCHING PLAYBOOKS WE
DEVELOPED FOR EVERY SINGLE
CIRCUIT IN OUR HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS. AND TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPACT OF THIS. THE BENEFITS OF
THIS APPROACH OUR LARGEST
TWENTY TWENTY EVENT STARTED ON
DECEMBER FOURTH WITH TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS IN SCOPE FOR
POTENTIAL POWER SHUT OFF BY
USING OUR PLAYBOOKS SAY MANY
CIRCUITS AND MONITORING REAL
TIME CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND
POSSIBLY SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS ROUGHLY ONE POINT 6%
OF OUR CUSTOMER BASE OR POWER
DOWN INSTEAD OF THE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND. ASSEMBLY POINT
WE WERE ABLE TO REDUCE THE
SCALE THAT EVENT BY MORE THAN
HALF. BY SEGMENTING OR
CIRCUITS. OF COURSE ARE BILLION
SEXUALIZE GREATER REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF IMPACTED CUSTOMERS IS
NOT MINIMISE HARDSHIPS FACED BY
THOSE WHO LIVE. WORK YOU GO TO
SCHOOL IN AREAS ARE WITHOUT
POWER FOR EXTENDED PERIODS OF
TIME. NOW WE KNOW FOR INSTANCE
THAT SOME CUSTOMERS FACE BACK
TO BACK U. S. B. AS WARNINGS.
AND SHUT OFFS. NEED TAXPAYER TO
SANTA ANA WINDS ARE REFERRED TO
EARLIER. AND THIS IS WHY
APPROVING OUR EXECUTION OF P.
S. B. S. DOING OUT WEST WHERE
POSSIBLE DOING IT BETTER. I'LL
BE OUR CUSTOMERS THROUGH THESE
EVENTS AND BE MORE TRANSPARENT
IS PART OF OUR UPDATED WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLAN. MORE RECENTLY
THESE ARE THE OBJECTIVES OF OUR
P. S. B. S. ACTUAL PLAN WE'VE
UNDERTAKEN FOLLOWING THE RECENT
HEARINGS WITH CDC CALORIE S.
CALIFORNICA. OUR CUSTOMERS
DEMAND REFERENCE EARLIER THIS
DISCUSSION. OUR GOAL IS ALWAYS
TO USE POWERSHOT ALSO AS A LAST
RESORT PROTECTING LIVES AND
PROPERTY OF THE PEOPLE WE SERVE
WHEN WEATHER AND FIRE DANGER
CONDITIONS DEMANDED. IN FACT
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY. OPPOSE B. S. B. S.
PATROLSSHOULD SIXTY INCIDENTS
OF WIND RELATED DAMAGE THE
COULD HAVE POTENTIALLY CAUSING
NATION'S. THERE ARE LIKELY MANY
MORE. NOW WE DO HAVE PROTOCOLS
IN PLACE TO ENSURE P. S. B. S.
IS IN FACT A MEASURE OF LAST
RESORT. YOU HAD TO TROLLS
CONDUCTED FORTY EIGHT HOURS IN
ADVANCE TO REVIEW AND FORECAST
REAL TIME WEATHER DATA.
PROVIDED BY OUR EXTENSIVE
NETWORK OF WEATHER STATIONS.
SWITCHING RECONFIGURING
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE NOT IN SCOPE
FOR OUR SHUT OFF. AND MEETING
WITH A PUBLIC AGENCY PARTNERS
ARE NUMBER OF FACTORS AND
FORMER DECISION TO DE ENERGIZE
A CIRCUIT AT THE TIME DECISIONS
MAY. NOW WITH THAT SAID WE KNOW
THERE'S A LOT WE CAN IMPROVE ON
I'M CONFIDENT OF THE WORKERS
OUTLINED. OUR WATER MITIGATION
PLAN. AND P. S. B. S. ACTUAL
PLAN ALLOWS REDUCE THE
FREQUENCY AND SCOPE ARGYROS.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A TASK FORCE
REVIEWING SEVENTY TWO CIRCUITS
IN OUR SERVICE AREA THAT HAVE
BEEN MOST FREQUENTLY IMPACTED
BY T. S. B. S. THOSE
EXPERIENCING FOUR OR MORE
DEREGISTRATION SINCE TWENTY
NINETY. NOW WE PRIORITIZE THE
CIRCUITS FOR XCELERATED
MEDICATIONS WE CAN DEPLOY HEAD
OF THIS YEAR'S THE FIRE SEASON.
FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPEDITE OUR
GREAT HARDING EFFORTS AND SOME
OF THE CIRCUITS. WHICH IN TURN
LACERATION WINDSPEED THRESHOLDS
FOR DEREGISTRATION. LIKEWISE
WHEN STYLING MORE AUTOMATED
SWITCHING DEVICES TO ISOLATE
AND DE ENERGIZED CIRCUITS MAKE
SEGMENTS A SMALLER LEVEL. WE'VE
ALREADY COMPLETED MULTIPLE
CIRCUIT REVIEWS AND WE EXPECT
TO SEE TANGIBLE BENEFITS THIS
YEAR AS A RESULT. I DO A
COMBINATION SWITCHING
INSTALLATION COVER CONDUCTOR
AND OTHER MEDICATIONS THERE'S A
HIGH LIKELIHOOD WE'LL SEE
SERVICE PROGRESS FROM REDUCE B.
S. B. AS THE REGION. FULLY
MITIGATE MEANING NO PSP
RESIDENTS FOR SOME CIRCUITS. AS
A HIGHLIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RACES DISTRICT ZERO LIKES
COMMUNITY IN THE CITY OF
FONTANA IS NO LNGER SUBJECT TO
P. S. P. S. OFFENSE AFTER ABLE
TO RECONFIGURE AND MAKE
UPGRADES TO OUR ELECTORAL
SYSTEM. AND ARRANGE THE CIRCUIT
SO IT NO LONGER HAS OVERHEAD.
ASSETS IN HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS.
ALSO IN THIS SO OFFER. AND AREA
LIKE SIMI VALLEY. MAHOOD ARTIST
IDEAS B. S. ONE OF THE AREAS
WHERE WE BEEN THE MOST
INNOVATIVE IN OUR YES YES YES
PROGRAM IS SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS. WE HAVE A HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX HIGH DEFINITION
CAMERAS WE GIVE US AND LOCAL
FIRE AUTHORITIES I SPENT ALMOST
ALL OF OUR HARDWARE CIRCUITS SO
WE CAN SPOT FIRES EASILY EARLY
RESPOND QUICKLY. NOW WE ALSO
HAVE A THOUSAND WEATHER
STATIONS IN OUR CIRCUITS TO
PROVIDE LOCALIZED REAL TIME
WEATHER DATA. IS PART OF OUR PS
GAS ACTION PLAN WHILE FOR
MITIGATION PLAN RALLY EVEN MORE
THESE WEATHER STATIONS. THIS
NEW START BILLION LOOK AT WIND
AND RELATIVE HUMIDITY FOR
SPECIFIC CIRCUIT SEGMENTS.
ALLOWING US TO BE FAR MORE
TARGETED EXECUTING PARTIAL LOSS
AS WE GO FORWARD. OVERALL THESE
ENHANCE RESTORE WHETHER FEELS
FORECASTING BETTER INFORMED.
DECISION MAKING DURING P. S. B.
S. OPERATIONS. RECEIVE ACCURACY
AND PRECISION OF NOTIFICATIONS
AS WELL AS REDUCE THE VARIANCE
BETWEEN CUSTOMERS NOTIFIED AND
DOES THE ENERGIZED. WELL THE
PRIMARY FOCUS OF OUR PSP HAS
ACTUAL PLAN IS ON REDUCING THE
SCOPE AND DURATION OF THE SPS
OFFENSE WE DO PLAN TO IMPROVE
OUTRAGE IN COORDINATION WITH
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY AND AGENCY
PARTNERS. STARTING IN FEBRUARY
WE BEGAN MEETING MONTHLY WITH
CALLAWAY YES THE LION STANDARD
OPERATING GUIDES. PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES. THIS MUST ONE GAUGE
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS TO
SOLICIT FEEDBACK R. P. S. B. S.
PROTOCOLS AND PREPAREDNESS.
AGAIN OUR GOAL IS TO USE
PARTIALS AS A LAST RESORT TO
PROTECT THE PROPERTY. AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SEARCH. USING A
PS PS IS A LAST RESORT MEANS
THAT WILDFIRE PREVENTION IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR WORK YEAR
ROUND. ESPS IN SPITE OF THE
CHALLENGES POSED BY COMING
NINETEEN WE MET OR EXCEEDED
NEARLY ALL THE GOALS THAT ARE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
MITIGATION PLAN. INCLUDING
INSTALLING OVER NINE HUNDRED
SIXTY CIRCUIT MILES OF
INSULATED WIRE OVER SIX
THOUSAND BY RESISTING CALLS.
AND ALMOST SIX HUNDRED WEATHER
STATIONS WHILE REMOVING MORE
THAN TWELVE THOUSAND HAZARD
TREES THAT COULD FALL INTO
POWER LINES AND LEAD TO AN
AGAINST. I RECENTLY UPDATED
WATER MITIGATION PLAN BUILDS ON
THE WORK COMPLETED IN TWENTY
TWENTY. AND LAYS OUT A PATH TO
FURTHER REDUCE RISK ON OUR
SYSTEM. MANY OF THESE
ACTIVITIES WILL BE ACCELERATED
TO R. P. S. B. AS ACTION PLAN
AS WELL. REDUCING THE SCALE AND
DURATION OF THE SPS EVENTS IS
JUST ONE OF THE AREAS IN WHICH
WE'RE COMMITTED. TO CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT. AND THIS TIME I
LIKE TO ASK MY COLLEAGUE JILL.
SURE HOW WE'VE MADE
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR CUSTOMER
CARE AND COMMUNICATIONS-
GERALDINE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M JILL ANDERSON I'M
THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
CUSTOMER SERVICE THAT I SEE.
AND I WANT TO START OUT MY
THING AS THE HEAD OF CUSTOMER
SERVICE. I READ ALL THE
FRUSTRATED AND ANGRY POSTS THAT
WE GET FROM CUSTOMERS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. I LISTENED DIRECTLY TO
THE CUSTOMER PHONE CLLS THAT
COME INTO OUR CONTACT CENTER I
SPOKE IN IT MULTIPLE PUBLIC
MEETINGS AND I'VE HEARD HOURS
OF PUBLIC COMMENT. AND I HEAR
OUR WHOLE TEAM HERE'S AND WE
UNDERSTAND. THE OUTRAGE FROM
THE CUSTOMERS WHO'VE BEEN
IMPACTED ESPECIALLY THOSE
MULTIPLE TIMES. AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION AND
CONFUSION THAT MANY. OF OUR
CUSTOMERS HAVE SHARED. WE HAVE
A LOT TO STILL IMPROVE BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT THAT WE ARE THAT WE ARE
PROUD OF THAT WE CAN PERCENT
TWENTY NINETEEN. EXPANDED OUR
USE OF COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS AND EXPANDED OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES DURING PS PS EVENTS
WE'VE- IMPROVED OUR WEBSITE
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY. BUT
I WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT WE
HEAR OUR CUSTOMERS WE HEAR OUR
REGULATORS WE HEAR EACH OF YOU.
AND THAT WE ARE WORKING ON AND
COMMITTED TO IMPROVING OUR
CUSTOMERS EXPERIENCE I'M FULLY
COMMITTED TO THAT. IN ABASED
ON THE FEEDBACK FROM OUR
CUSTOMERS SPECIFICALLY AND ALSO
FROM THE REGULATORS WE KNOW
THERE'S A MULTIPLE AREAS THAT
WE HAVE TO OF ALL THE AND IT
HAS TO BE DONE VERY QUICKLY WE
ARE MAKING CHANGES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE IN PLACE BEFORE THE
NEXT FIRE SEASON. CENTRAL TO
THAT AND YOU HEARD SOME OF THE
STATISTICS ALREADY OUR
NOTIFICATIONS. PROVIDING
CUSTOMERS TIMELY AND ACCURATE
AND ACTIONABLE INFORMATION
ESPECIALLY DURING EMERGENCIES
LIKE PS PS IS OUR TOP PRIORITY.
WE'RE ADDRESSING RIGHT NOW WITH
SOME OF THE ROOT CAUSES ARE FOR
Y. MESSAGES IN THE PAST HAVE
CREATED CUSTOMER CONFUSION.
LIKE TOO MANY NOTICES OR COME
SOME CUSTOMERS HAVE RECEIVED
MESSAGES THAT ARE ACCURATE AND
RELEVANT TO MULTIPLE CIRCUITS
THAT ARE IN THEIR AREA BUT
NIGHT MIGHT NOT BE SPECIFIC TO
THE CIRCUIT THAT SERVES THEIR
HOUSE. WE HAVE TO IMPROVE THESE
NOTICES AND IN THE ACTION PLAN
THAT PHIL MENTIONED THAT WE
FILED IN FEBRUARY IN HIS
CENTRAL THEME FOR US WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF DOING OUR INTENT
AND REVIEW OF THE PROCESS AND
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMISSION WHEN WE MIGHT WANT
TO MODIFY THE NUMBER OF
MESSAGES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED. AND WE'RE MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE DESIGNING THIS BASED
ON CUSTOMER FEEDBACK SO THAT IT
CAN BE EFFECTIVE IN MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE CUSTOMERS AS THEY
EXPLAIN. TO US. IN ADDITION THE
NOTIFICATIONS ANOTHER AREA IT'S
TRULY IMPORTANT TO US IS MAKING
SURE THAT OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
PREPARED. FOR ANY EMERGENCY WE
KNOW THAT WEATHER CONDITIONS
ARE JUST GOING TO GET MORE
EXTREME. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
OUR GREAT HARDENING UPGRADES TO
MINIMIZE THE YOU DISAPPEAR YES.
IT AND THAT'S A MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENT PROCESS AND SO WE
ARE HELPING OUR CUSTOMERS IN
THE MEANTIME BUILD RESILIENCY
FOR THEIR HOMES AND BUILDING
RESILIENCY FOR. THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I'VE BEEN PART OF
THAT IS MINIMIZED THE IMPACT OF
PS PS AND SO I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TWO AREAS IN PARTICULAR.
I WON THE PRESIDENT BACHELOR
MENTIONED ALREADY ARE CRITICAL
CARE BATTERY BACKUP PROGRAM WE
LAUNCHED THIS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE YEAR LAST YEAR AND
INITIALLY FOCUSED ON OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION. I WOULD
CHOOSE WE HAVE DESIGNATED AS
CRITICAL CARE WITHIN MEDICAL
BASELINE WE HAVE ALREADY
EXPANDED THIS OFFERING NOW TO
ALL OF THE ELIGIBLE MEDICAL
BASELINE CUSTOMERS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE'VE LAUNCHED
MARKETING AND OUTREACH TO THOSE
CUSTOMERS JUST IN THE PAST FEW
WEEKS WE'RE BUILDING ON THE
LESSONS THAT WE LEARNED IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE. CREATED AND WE HAVE TO AT
TIMES BE PERSISTENT IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURETHAT WE'RE REACHING
CUSTOMERS AND INSTALLING
BATTERIES THAT WE KNOW. PROVIDE
SO MUCH BENEFIT FOR THEM. ON
THE COMMUNITY SIDE. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
COMMUNITIES OF PRESIDENT BADGER
MENTIONS THE NEED VALLEY. I'VE
BEEN THINKING MULTIPLE ONES
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
MULTIPLE TIMES DURING EVENTS.
SO WE HAVE ALREADY STARTED
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE RESILIENCY
ZONES WHERE WE ARE ABLE TO
DEPLOY BACKUP GENERATION TO
POWER LOCAL. MARKETS ARE GAS
STATIONS ARE YOU KNOW A
BUSINESS CENTER. DURING A PS PS
EVENT. AND YOU KNOW AS AS I
WRAP UP THERE'S TO CUSTOMER
INTERACTIONS AROUND PS PS THAT
I WANT. TO SHARE WITH YOU. THE
STRAIGHT HOW. MATT JANUARY
EVENT WHICH HAS WAS AS
MENTIONED BEFORE. WEATHER
EVENTS AND MUCH STEP. WHEN WE
THOUGHT THE FORECAST. COMING
THAT WE WERE GONNA GET.
EXTREMELY HIGH WINDS.
CLEAR AND
DIRECT ENGAGEMENT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER AS A TEAM TO KEEP THE
PUBLIC SAFE SO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SURE
HOLDEN BY SHARE PATTERSON AND
RESPECTED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE IN SESSION TODAY MY
NAME IS A MONSTER BANG AND I'M
PRIVILEGED TO BE PEONIES
CHAMBERS COSTS ARE. I'M SURE IN
ABOUT. TWENTY TWENTY SAFETY
POWERSHOT EVENT. RENDON'S MOVE
MAY TO LESSEN THE- HAS BEEN
STATED OUR YOURSELF TROUBLED.
AS ACTOR OF THE IMPACT OF U. S.
B. BETWEEN TWO NINETEEN TO
TWENTY ARMENIANS A SECOND WAY.
FOR A LOT FEEDBACK. A LOT OF
FEEDBACK- AND ACTED UPON THAT
WE HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE I THINK
GOING FORWARD WE'RE COMMITTED
TO THAT AND I WILL ALSO.
DISCUSS SOME OTHER FOCUS AREAS
THAT WE HAVE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE I SPECIFICALLY SOME OF THE
AREAS ARE HIGHLIGHTED BY
PRESIDENT BADGER. IN HER
OPENING REMARKS- AS- BILL
HEARING TO NORTH COAST THE
CLIMATE CHANGES ARE WE GOING TO
SEE OUR THE WE DON'T AND WEIGH
ACROSS THE WEST S. AND TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA OREGON
WASHINGTON ALL EXPERIENCED ON
THE MOST ACTIVE IN DAMAGING
WILDFIRE SEASONS IN THE HISTORY.
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE THE LARGEST
WILDFIRE SEASON WILL BE
EXPERIENCE CLOSE TO HOME IN
CALIFORNIA. IN FACT LET ME
SERVICE TERRITORY. NEARLY THREE
MILLION ACRES BURNED LAST YEAR
WHICH WAS NEARLY THREE TIMES
THE PRIOR THREE YEAR AVERAGE.
MPD SERVICE TERRITORY ALONE HAS
NEARLY TRIPLED. AS THE ELEVATED
RISK A LOT OF FIRE FROM 15% TO
MORE THAN FIFTY MORE THAN 50%
OVER THE PAST DECADE. GIVEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
AUTHORIZED THE WERE SEEING IN
THE BANK'S NAME THE FIRE
SEASON. PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF REMAINS AN IMPORTANT
BUT A MEASURE OF LAST RESORT
OUR TOOL. FOR CUSTOMERS HI
COMMITTEE SAFE. MOST OF
RECOGNIZED THE LOSING POWER
LIVES ESPECIALLY FOR CUSTOMERS
WHO RELY ON ELECTRICITY FOR.
LIFE SUSTAINING. SURVIVALIST IN
TO OUR CUSTOMERS AND
COMMUNITIES HELLO COMMUNITIES
AND FINDING WAYS TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT YES S. ADVANCED WITHOUT
COMPROMISING SAFETY. AGAIN
THERE'S- THAT WE LOOK AT PS PS
AS A MEASURE OF LAST RESORT. WE
HAVE SIX YES YES I MENTIONED
TWENTY TWENTY THAT WOULD
PROCEED WITH THE NATIONS ONE
ALREADY THIS YEAR IN JANUARY
WHICH HAS BEEN UNPRECEDENTED
AND NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE IN
OUR SERVICE TERRITORY. TWENTY
NINETEEN- THE EVENT'S IMPACTED
YOUR CUSTOMERS- AND OUR AVERAGE
RESTORATION TIMES FOR FASTER.
IN TWENTY TWENTY- WE IMPACTED
55% YOUR CUSTOMERS AS COMPARED
TO SIMILAR WEATHER CONDITIONS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN. AS MISS
CARLA JACOB THOMAS ALSO STATED
IN OUR- FAX. LARGEST DRIVER OF
THIS REDUCTION WAS IMPROVED
WEATHER FORECASTING THE ABILITY
FOR US TO BE MUCH MORE GRANULAR
IN DEVELOPING FOR US I'M TO
TARGET- THE RISK ASSOCIATED
WITH WILDFIRES BLACK WE ALSO
TARGET THE INTERNALIZATION FROM
A P. S. P. S. PERSPECTIVE.
BETTER TRANSMISSIONS. UP
PROCESS. WE CONTINUE TO INVEST.
IN OUR GENERATING STATION LIKE
THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY GENERATING
STATION THAT PROVIDES I WAS TO
KEEP THE BUILDINGS NOW. ALSO
THAT THAT THE TRANSMISSION
LINES THAT ARE FEEDING PEOPLE
VOTE COUNTY COMMUNITY AT THEIR
IMPACTED OTHERS ALL THE P. S.
P. S. THAT COMMUNITY I CAN BE
SUSTAINED- OR- THE DURATION OF
THE EVENT. ENDOSOMAL TO WHAT
MISTER HERRINGTON- HIGHLIGHTS
FOR US HE R. WITH THE CAN YOU
TO MAKE IN THE GOING TO. LIKE
SOCIALIZATION DEVICES.
TEMPORARY MIGHT. I IN ALL OF
THOSE- CAME TO BEAR IN TWENTY
TWENTY THAT HELP WITH THE
REDUCTION OF FIFTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF YOUR CUSTOMERS
IMPACTED. HOW ALSO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT IT TOOK SEE IF YOU POWER
AFTER THE WEATHER HAD PASSED BY
NEW 40% I TO DO- WE MOBILIZE
MORE THAN THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
QUALIFIED ON THE GROUND
PERSONNEL. SUPPORTING
INSPECTION EFFORTS. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE SIX FORMER BANDS
WE IDENTIFIED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN DAMAGES OR HAZARDS THAT
OTHERWISE HAVE YOU NOT THE
OTHER GUYS GOING TO
POTENTIALLY. YIELDED OR
RESULTED IN ADDITION OR A
SPARK. WE DEPLOYED SIXTY FIVE
HELICOPTERS TO INSPECT THE
LINES FROM THE ERROR- WE ALSO
DEPLOYED AN AIRPLANE THAT WAS
QUITE A LOT OF TECHNOLOGY SO
THAT WE CAN INSPECT THE LIGHTS
AT NIGHT. AND NOT LOSE THAT
TIME I WAS THE ADVERSE WEATHER
FASTER SERVICE TERRITORY. WE
PROVIDED OUR CUSTOMERS BETTER
INFORMATION WE HAVE MORE WORK
TO DO WE RECOGNIZE THAT AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE COMMITTED TO
DOING. OUR BOTH BEFORE DURING
AND AFTER. PS PS EVENTS. ARE WE-
MORE THAN TWELVE IN CATIONS.
SIXTEEN TO PROVIDE. PROVIDED
MORE THAN FIVE- PACKAGES ARE
PARTNERING UP WITH SCHOOL BANKS.
I'M TO THE POINT THAT THAT MADE
HAD MORE THAN SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED OR MORE ABOUT. FROM TO.
ARE VULNERABLE BASED CUSTOMER.
HI AND WELCOME TO DOING. I'LL
COME UPON THE IN A SENSE. I AM
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
CUSTOMERS THAT WE SERVE THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH A MULTITUDE
OF DIFFERENT COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. OUR ENGAGE WITH
TO. SUPPORT THEM WITH HOTEL
VOUCHERS TRANSPORTATION AND
OTHER CRITICAL RESOURCES- WE
USE A MULTITUDE OF DIFFERENT
AVENUES TO PARTNER AND ENGAGE
WITH OUR AGENCIES MOVE BACK OF
WORKING SESSIONS WE COLLECTED
THIRTY TWO WORKING SESSIONS OF
TWENTY TWENTY. MANY OF OUR
CITIES COUNTIES- TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES- AND WILL BE
HOLDING MORE SESSIONS IF ALL
THIS YEAR- WE'VE GOT A LISTING
SESSIONS. I WOULD HAVE THIRTY
SIX- FOLLOWING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN PS PS EVENTS AND WE'VE
ALREADY DONE FORTY ONE EVENTS-
MOSTLY SESSION PERSPECTIVE
POSTED TWENTY TWENTY EVENTS.
WERE TAKING ALL THAT
INFORMATION ALL THAT FEEDBACK
OF THE GIFT OF FEEDBACK TO
COMPUTER COUPON. HOW WE SUPPORT
OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. I WILL STARTED
ONLINE SURVEYS- TO AGENCIES ARE
IMPACTED BY THE EVENTS. THAT
YOU BEGAN THIS PRACTICE MIDWAY
LAST YEAR- AND WE'VE CONDUCTED
THREE SURVEYS TO DATE AND THAT
THE FEEDBACK THAT WE RECEIVED
IS BY MORE THAN 89% OF THE
AGENCIES THAT WERE SURVEYED.
THE EVENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY
GOOGLE TWENTY NINETEEN. BUT
THAT JUST TO REINFORCE. THAT WE
HAVE MORE WORK TO BE ABLE.
SOMETIMES TO THAT TWENTY ONE
FOCUS THAT WE- THE LAW ARE SAFE
EFFORTS AS ALSO OUTLINED THEM.
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIVE
EDUCATION. WILL CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE AND IMPROVE THEM EVERY
YEAR TO REPLY THE LESSONS
LEARNED- BRING TO IN. INCLUDING
FEEDBACK FROM ACROSS ARE TO. OF
THIS. AREA FOR US OF THE- YEAH
YES AND THAT'S A TWENTY. THIS
CAN TO IN UPON ELECTRICAL WHICH
IS. THE INSTALL. OF BORDER. OF
MORE MATURE AND FIFTY. ALSO
GOOD TO UPGRADE. ON MICHAEL. WE
CAN BRING TO OUR TEMPORARY CHEN
PEOPLE ON THE STRENGTH. CORSON
YES YES- ON THE- FROM FOR
TWENTY THE COOKING PART. WITH
CITIES K. AND- TO THE BATTERY.
FOR BETTER. AND SUPPORT. FOR
CPAS TO THE THAT PRESENT BADGER-
WE ARE TO STAY UP FOR BATTERIES
PROGRAM WHERE THEY DOUBLE THAT.
TWENTY TWO. ALL AND REALLY-
WITH THE BOCA ON MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE. THAT THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE COME BACK
WILL BE FINE MORE I THOUGHT BUT
THIS ARE CARD ESTIMATE. BY
THIRTY. HOW WITH OUR SERVICE
FOR- IN TO THE IN. SHE WAS THE
AGENCY GALLAGHER PROBLEM. WE
HAVE ONE OF GROUP LOCAL YOU
HAVE. TO ORDER AND- OUR IN.
PROTOCOL SO WE HAVE SPECIAL
FIELD ON THE IMPROVEMENTS WHICH
WOULD TO BE A- THE WE GET INTO
THE TWENTY. ONE PS PSC'S. ALL
OF THE- IN REGARDS TO THE
CUSTOMER IMPROVEMENTS- WE'VE
GOT FOCUS ON IMPROVING OUR
CONSISTENCY ACROSS LOCATION
ACCURACY I WE MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN TWENTY TWENTY AS
COMPARED TO TWENTY NINETEEN I
SPORTFISHING ACCURACY GROUP OF
ABOUT 90% IN TWENTY NINETEEN
MORE THAN 99% OF TWENTY TWENTY
WE HAVE MORE TO DO- OUR MAKING
MY MODIFICATIONS MARKETS. BASED
ON. AND ALSO PRODUCT PROCESS
ALSO THAT WE GET SOME BY THAT
MAY COME OUT OF SCHOOL BUT IT
WAS OF WHICH THAT ARE FROM THE
INITIAL FOR EIGHT HOURS OF THE
NO THERE ARE OF SCHOOL BECAUSE
YOU. TO STAY WITH. ALSO GOING
TO CONTINUE OUR- WITH THE
NETWORK OF THE COMMUNICATION OR
NOT. WHICH INCLUDES BANKS AND
LIKE OR NOT THEY- WILL NOT BE.
IN THE- LIVING CENTER. IN
ADDITION TO ALL THE WORK WE'RE
DOING TO POOREST WE ARE. TO
MONITOR THE WEATHER. ALL HIGH
DEF CAMERA THAT YOU OF THE SO
LIKE IF. FOR AWARENESS PROVIDE
MORE ACT. NOT LINE AS A WHOLE.
LOOKING AT P. S. P. S. ARE ON A
MORE INTIMATE BASIS AS WE
STARTED. HARD TO MAKE GREAT
PROGRESS. IN DOING THAT AND
ALSO THE SAME TIME FRIEND FIND
GREAT THROUGHOUT. SO THAT WE
CAN TO BE MORE TARA. AND
REFUSED NEED FOR PSP- THAT-
OVER TIME I WANT TO TAKE ALL-
ARE. VERY EXCITED ABOUT WHAT'S
USED IN AUSTRIA OF RAPID ALL
CURRENT LIMITER. AUTOMATICALLY
AND- REDUCES A SMALL ON THE
REST OF THE- A LOT OF POTENTIAL
FOR. THAT I UNDERSTAND. WITHOUT
AT ONE OF OUR CIRCUITS THIS.
AND WILL BE COMPLETING BE-
OPERATION COMMISSIONING OF THAT
JULY OF THIS YEAR NOT TO BE A
LOT. A GOOD GROUP RIGHT- TO
EXPAND. I'LL BE ON THE YEAR. ON
YOU AGAIN. SHAREHOLDERS. GOOD
AFTERNOON HAS ONE TOO QUICK
SOUNDCHECK AND CAN YOU GUYS
HEAR ME. AND HEAR YOU. THANK
YOU- THANK YOU- CHAIR HOLDEN
VICE CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN JENKINS
I'M STANDING IN GAS ELECTRIC SO
VICE PRESIDENT OF ELECTRIC
SYSTEM OPERATIONS AND WHILE
PERMEATION- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. BE HERE TODAY
TO DISCUSS THE EXECUTION OF OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
PROGRAM. OF PERSONAL START OFF
WITH JUST A BRIEF REVIEW OF
THIS PAST FIRE SEASON- WHICH
OF. FROM THE COMMENTS YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD WAS PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING- THIS LAST FIRE
SEASON. FOR THE REGION IN SAN
DIEGO RIGHT ITS FIRST RE FLAG
WARNING- IN SEPTEMBER WHICH IS
REALLY EARLY FOR US WE'RE
TYPICALLY MORE OF- OCTOBER
EARLY NOVEMBER. TIME FRAME FOR
REPLY WARNINGS US WE HAD A
COUPLE IN SEPTEMBER- THEN THE
RED FLAG WARNING SEASON ALSO
GOT OFF TO A PLATE AND- GOING
ALL THE WAY INTO JANUARY WITH
TWO EVENTS- IN MID JANUARY- SO-
WE HAD AN EXTENDED RED FLAG
WARNING SEASON. WE ALSO HAD A
MORE FREQUENCY OF RED FLAG
WARNING ADVANCE- WE AVERAGE
ABOUT THREE PER YEAR- WE HAD
ELEVEN IN THAT SEPTEMBER
THROUGH JANUARY TIME FRAME- AND
NOT ONLY DID WE SEE A LONGER
SEASON WITH MORE FREQUENCY OF
EVENTS BUT WE ALSO EXPERIENCED
IN AN EXTREMELY STRONG EVENT-
ONE. ONE IN PARTICULAR THAT WAS
ON DECEMBER SECOND THROUGH THE
FOURTH. I JUST WANNA SPEND ONE
MINUTE AND GIVE YOU SOME
STATISTICS FROM HER MARCHING
THEM BECAUSE THIS IS OVER HALF
OF THE CUSTOMER HOURS THAT
THAT- DIRECTOR JACOBS MENTIONED
IN OUR STATISTICS. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY. WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED
WHETHER. FOR LOCATED- IN A
SERVICE. NOW MOST WHICH HAVE
BEEN. WEATHER DATA FOR OVER A
DECADE- TO PROVIDE US WITH
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS REGARDING
POTENTIAL FIRE WEATHER- FOR
TWELVE TWELVE THROUGH TWELVE
FOR THE AVERAGE TOP AGHAST AT
TWENTY WEATHER STATIONS BUT SAW
THE STRONGEST WINDS WAS SEVENTY
ONE MILES PER HOUR- NOT ALWAYS
NEXT TIME WAS WHEN I WAS THE
AVERAGE. OF THE PEAK OF WIND AT
THE WEATHER STATION THAT SAW
THE HIGHEST WIND WAS NINETY
FOUR MILES PER HOUR AT ARE
STILL WHO WEATHER STATION- ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX OVER TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY WEATHER STATIONS
SO OVER HALF. ARE RECORDED WIND
SPEEDS IN THE NINETY NINTH
PERCENTILE MEANING THAT THEY
ONLY SEE THAT ONE SPEED 1% OF
THE TIME- AND THEN- EVEN MORE-
COMPELLING THE MAP WAS FORTY
THREE OF THE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
WEATHER STATIONS SO. A ROUGHLY
20% RECORDED THEIR ALL TIME
HIGH WITH OVER I LIKE I SAID
TEN YEARS OF WEATHER DATA THAT
WE'VE BEEN COLLECTING. A 20%
SAW THEIR ALL TIME RECORD
BROKEN IN THAT ONE EVENT- JUST
PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
PERSPECTIVE WE SAW RECORD GUSTS
OF SIXTY MILES PER HOUR I DEL
MAR ON THE COAST I JUST GIVE
YOU AN IDEA OF HOW WIDESPREAD
THE ABOUT WAS FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT ARE FAMILIAR WITH- THE SAN
DIEGO REGION- THIS BECAUSE THIS
HUGE NEED TO NOTIFY NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS. OF
THE POTENTIAL OF PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF- WE ENDED UP THE
ENERGIZING SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND A LITTLE OVER THAT OF
THEIR OF THOSE CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS- WE OPEN TEN COMMUNITY
RESOURCE. CENTERS AS A RESULT
AND SONYA B. TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED CARS DRIVE THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTER WE
WERE NOT. A DRIVE THRU FORMAT
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC SITUATION-
THIS WAS MORE TRAFFIC THAN
WE'VE- SEEN EVEN AND NOT OF THE
WALK UP TYPE- COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE PAST- SO. HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT WE'RE USING THIS
TOOLS AS A MEASURE OF LAST
RESORT- I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THAT WE- ESTY GENIE AND I
PERSONALLY- TAKE THE UTMOST
CARE WHEN MAKING THESE
DECISIONS- WE DO NOT TAKE THESE
DECISIONS LIGHTLY- EVEN IN THE
A LARGE EVENT IN DECEMBER. WE
DO ENERGIZED OVER EIGHTY
DIFFERENT CIRCUIT SEGMENTS TO
MAKE UP THAT SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND CUSTOMER ACCOUNT
NUMBER- THAT IS OVER EIGHTY
SEPARATE DECISIONS THEY WERE
MAKING USING INFORMATION FOR
EVERYONE OF THOSE DECISIONS FOR
MORE WEATHER STATIONS. TEN
YEARS OF HISTORICAL DATA THE
ABILITY TO GET WINDS GUSTS
REACHED DOWN AT THE THIRTY
SECOND INTERVAL LEVEL- WHICH
WAS- IMPROVEMENT- IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN OUR
WEATHER STATIONS. USING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE TO
INFORM FORECASTING MODELS ARE
ALSO USING MACHINE LEARNING- WE
HAVE ESTROGEN INSPIRE POTENTIAL
INDEX. TO ASSESS THE
CONDITIONS. WERE VERY
PARTICULAR FIRE WEATHER EVENTS-
WE ALSO HAVE A VEGETATION RISK
INDEX WHICH IDENTIFIES FOR
SPECIFIC AREAS- HISTORICAL
VEGETATION CONTACTS SPECIES OF
TREES THE PROXIMITY OF THE
TREES TO THE LINES. OF GROWTH
RATES OF THE TREES ALL THIS
GIVES US- OF EDUCATION RISKY
NEXT FOR EVERYONE. OF THE
SEGMENTS THAT THAT I WAS
DESCRIBING. AND ALSO FEEL
OBSERVER. AS WELL AS PIECES
MACRAME ALL GO TO DO. MAKE
PROCESS- AFTER AFTER THE
PATROLS DURING THE STRONG
EVENTS WAITED A FIVE FOURTEEN
ISSUES THAT NEEDED TO BE
CORRECTED PRIOR TO US BEING
ABLE TO SAFELY REENERGIZE THE
SYSTEM- THESE RANGE FROM
VEGETATION AND DEBRIS AND OUR
LINES TO- YEAH BROKEN CROSS ARM-
I WANTED TO WALK THROUGH THAT
WORST OF INTERESTED TO KIND OF
PAINT THE PICTURE BUT I ALSO
WANT TO GIVE YOU A PICTURE OF
WHAT TRANSPIRED THE REST OF THE
RED FLAG WARNING SEASON- I
MENTIONED WE HAD ELABORATE BY
MORNING ADVANCE- AND TO.
FURTHER ILLUSTRATE ONLY USING
THIS IS A MEASURE OF LAST
RESORT WE- USED PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTIAL OFTEN IN SIX OF THE
ELEVEN EVENTS- WE THE NEXT
LARGEST ONE FROM THE SEVENTY
THREE THOUSAND CUSTOMER COUNT
WAS FIFTEEN THOUSAND CUSTOMERS-
THEN WE HAD TWO EVENTS THAT
WERE LESS THAN TEN THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS. ONE EVENT THAT WAS
FOUR HUNDRED CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS
AND THEN ONE OF AND IT WAS
ACTUALLY LESS THAN A HUNDRED
CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS AND- THOSE
ARE MORE ARE TYPICAL OF PS PS-
ADVANCING IMPACTS- SO EVEN
TELLS. OF THE TREATMENTS. WERE
WORKING OVER ONCE IN THE PAST.
OUR BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT OF
THIS BETTER SHORT TERM ACCORDED
NOT EXPERIENCE A SIGNIFICANT
WHILE CAUSED BY OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IN FACT WE
WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO ONLY
HAVE- ONE SIGNIFICANT OF. THAT
IMPACT OUR SERVICE TERRITORY
NOW WITH THE VALLEY FIRE IN
SEPTEMBER- HAVING SAID ALL THIS
WE UNDERSTAND THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF IT IS AN
IMPACT AND THE SEVERE IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE-
WE'RE STRIVING TO MINIMIZE THAT
IMPACT SO WE'RE GOING TO.
CONTINUE TO EXAMINE WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN DO THAT BY
ACTIVELY- FIRST WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PARTNER
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM- AS AS OF
THE END OF 202098% OF OUR
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM INTERIOR
THREE- HAS BEEN HARDENED SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. 83% OF THE
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM OVERALL IN
THE CHIPPY HAS BEEN HARDENED-
THIS ALLOWS US TO KEEP OUR
TRANSMISSION SYSTEM ENERGIZED-
DURING OUR WEATHER CONDITIONS
WHICH KEEPS LARGE POPULATIONS
ENERGIZED AND- KEEPING US FROM
THE ENERGIZING ENTIRE
SUBSTATIONS THAT MAY NOT NEED
TO BE DE ENERGIZED. ARE
OTHERWISE- WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND AND WEBER JR
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS TOOLS-
EVERY YEAR WE GO THROUGH
LESSONS LEARNED AND FIND NEW
PLACES WHERE WE WOULD LIKE TO
INSTALL WEATHER STATIONS.
ASSOCIATED SEXUALIZING DEVICES
WHICH INCREASE OUR GRANULARITY-
I'M ALSO GOING TO CONTINUE TO
ENHANCE OUR- FORECASTING WITH.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND
MACHINE LEARNING. HI WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE THE HARDEST
SYSTEM WE HARD OVER TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY OVERHEAD MILES IN TWENTY
TWENTY- WE'RE GOING TO AT LEAST
THAT SAME NUMBER THIS YEAR- WE-
AND IN THE WORST OF THE WORST
AREAS- UNDERGROUND AND OVERHEAD
AND- INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR THIRTY
MILES- WE'RE GOING TO BE
CONTINUING THAT- SAYING WHAT
WHAT BECKER IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. I'M TWENTY TWENTY WE
DEPLOYED FOR NEW MICRO GRIDS-
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE'RE
GONNA ADD TWO MORE- TO
ENERGIZED SOME TOWN CENTERS IN
OUR- BACK. COMMUNITY USED. AND
I ALWAYS LIKE TO ILLUSTRATE
THAT WITH THESE IT'S NOT JUST
THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS IT'S
THE TYPE OF CUSTOMERS THAT YOU
RE ENERGIZING HE'S OUR TOWN
CENTRES- SO A LOT OF THESE
PLACES JUST HAVE AN
INTERSECTION OR TWO THAT. IS
BASICALLY THE TOWN CENTER SO
IT'S GOING TO KEEP FOR FREE
STORES SCHOOLS- URGENT CARE
CENTERS GAS STATIONS- WITH OUR
DURING THE SITUATIONS SO. EVEN
IF WE'RE NOT MITIGATING IMPACTS
DIRECTLY BY ENERGIZING HOMES
WERE MITIGATING IMPACT BY.
PROVIDING CRITICAL GOODS AND
SERVICES TO PEOPLE INSPECT
ENTRY AREAS- WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND OUR CUSTOMER
RESILIENCY PROGRAMS- IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE- OFFERED OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED- PORTABLE
BATTERY STORAGE UNITS FOR
MEDICAL BASED ON CUSTOMERS.
THIS WAS EVERY CUSTOMER THAT
HAD EXPERIENCED A PS PS EVENT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN- WE HAD 85%
ACCEPTANCE RATE ON ON OUR
OFFERS- WE'RE PLANNING TO
EXPAND THAT PROGRAM TO OVER TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AGAIN TARGETING MEDICAL BASED
ON CUSTOMERS- WE ALSO STARTED.
A GENERATOR REBATE PROGRAM IN
TWENTY TWENTY SO CERTAIN
QUALIFYING CUSTOMERS- IN- ARE
HARPER TRAIT DISTRICT ARE
WRONG. PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF- WERE GIVEN A 50% REBATE A
THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR VALUE TO
PURCHASE A PORTABLE GENERATOR.
IF THEY WERE QUALIFYING LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS IT WAS A 75%
REBATE OR FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR VALUE- TO GO PURCHASE A
PORTABLE GENERATOR- AND THEN
JUST ONE LAST THE- INNOVATION
IN THAT I WOULD LIKE TO. LEAVE
YOU A THIS WERE FOR TO- WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND TWENTY TO COME
TO REDUCE RISK CASH FOR
WILDFIRE BUT ALSO. REDUCE THE
IMPACTS OF PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF- WE'RE USING- A RISK
AND THE RISK MODELING TOOL
RIVER WE REFER TO AS WINGS ARE
WILD OUR NEXT GENERATION
SYSTEM- THIS IS A RISK MODELING
TOOL THAT SG USES FOR OUR
PROJECTS SELECTION
PRIORITIZATION. BY QUANTIFYING
THE RISK REDUCTION BUT
DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES EXHIBIT.
BUT THE IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
CONTROLS THAT ALSO INCORPORATES
THE RISK OF PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF IN THE MODEL- PRIOR TO
THIS SDG WAS SELECTING A
PRIORITIZING PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS BASED ON THEIR ABILITY
TO REDUCE THE RISK OF ALL
PARAMOUNT. A WHICH DID NOT
NECESSARILY BENEFIT PS PS
REDUCTION- BUT THIS NEUTRALS
TAKING BOTH ASPECTS INTO
ACCOUNT SO THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR PATH GOING. FORWARD
FOR A LOT OF OUR PROGRAMS- WITH
THAT I WILL- CAN. MY IN MY
COMMENT HERE WILL GLADLY-
ANSWERED QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. WELL THANK
YOU AND- AND LET ME JUST AGAIN
THANK ALL OF YOU REPRESENTS OF
THE CPUC AND PRESENT BACHELOR
AND- THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES-
THAT IS THE UNIQUE ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY UNIQUE TO THIS
COMMITTEE. TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT- AND HEARING SUCH AS
WERE HAVING TODAY- TO NOT ONLY
LOOK AT THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AND
HOW THEY ADDRESS ISSUES AS WE
ARE FOCUSING TODAY ON. PS PS
EVENTS BUT ALSO THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES AS THEY OVERSEE AND
REGULATE. THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES SO WE HAVE THIS
IMPORTANT ROLE WHERE- CITIZEN
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES WE ARE
KIND OF IN THAT ROLE OF MAKING
SURE. THAT EVERYONE WHO HAS
JURISDICTION RESPONSIBILITY IS
DOING THE UP MOST- TO MEET
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES AND AS I
MADE REFERENCE IN MY- OPENING
COMMENTS- AS THE COMMENTS WERE
BEING SURE BACK TO PRESIDENT
VETERAN CPC ON HER BASED ON HER
LETTER- THERE HAS BEEN SORT OF
A- CLEAR PAPER TRAIL OF WHAT. A
UTILITIES AND SOME OF YOU ARE
DOING X. OR ARE MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS- LONG WAY TO GO A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE STILL OTHERS
ARE- HAVE SHOWN AT LEAST HERE
RECENTLY A STRUGGLING. MOMENTS
AND SO WE'RE WE HEAR OF
PRESENTATIONS AND I THINK YOUR
PRESENTATIONS LAID OUT
TECHNICALLY A LOT OF IMPORTANT-
NEXT STEPS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE TAKING. IT WE DON'T WANT TO
FALL INTO THAT CATEGORY OF
AGAIN WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
WHAT WE'RE PLANNING TO DO. AND
THEN WHEN THE MOMENT HITS YOU
DON'T PERFORM. AND SO I GUESS
MY- QUESTION- TO THE I. O. USE
AND IT'S FOR ALL OF YOU. AS WE
MOVE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. HOW
TO ASK QUESTIONS. IS WHAT DO
YOU THINK. THIS COMMITTEE OR
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY SHOULD DO%
WHEN A UTILITY REPEATEDLY FAILS
TO MEET ITS RESPONSIBILITIES
AND EXECUTION OF P. S. P. S.
EVENTS. I HAVE TO RUSH TO THE
MIGHT. I AM. CAROLYN THIS IS A
FULL ARTICLE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON FIRST I WANT
TO REITERATE SOMETHING- JOHN
ANDERSON FOR MEDICINE ALSO
SAID- JUST HOW FIRST OF ALL WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE WITH THIS COMMITTEE HERE
TODAY- HERE TO SPEAKERS AND
COLLABORATE ON WHAT WE THINK IS
THE CHALLENGE OF OUR TIME RIGHT
NOW WHICH IS CLIMATE CHANGE AND
CONSEQUENTLY WILDFIRE- OFFERS
RICH. COMING FROM THE- ASAKO
CHANGE- I RECOGNIZE MUCH MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE- CHAIRMAN
HOLDEN AYE AYE I WANT TO SAY
THAT I THINK- NEED GATE MORE
HAVING HERE TODAY IT IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AS WE-
ADJUST OUR PLANS AND
COMMUNICATE WHAT WE ARE DOING.
TO DO EVEN BETTER AND TO FIX
THINGS THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE ARE
WRONG I ALONG WITH KILLS- I
HAVE HEARD. MANY MANY
OBSERVATIONS FROM OUR
CUSTOMERS- FROM OUR-
STAKEHOLDERS FROM OUR PARTNERS
ABOUT THE NEED TO DO BETTER I
THINK THIS- COMMITTEE CAN HELP
IN THAT REGARD. BY HOLDING
THESE HEARINGS- HI YOU FORM FOR
US TO DISCUSS ANY FRAME UNDER.
WHERE WE'RE NOT MEETING THE
NEEDS AND EXPECTATIONS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. I DO BELIEVE THERE
IS A ROLE IN COLLABORATION
HERE- WITH ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND THIS INCLUDES
THE LEGISLATURE IN CALIFORNIA-
BECAUSE MUCH OF WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS UNIQUE I JUST WANT TO
REMIND. ALL OF US THAT IT'S IN
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AS EVIDENCED BY THE SIZE AND
PREVALENCE OF WILDFIRES. WE ARE
GAME DEALING WITH SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY NEW- IN THIS
CERTAINLY IN MY CAREER-THE
NOTION OF THE ENERGIZING
CUSTOMERS THIS IS JUST NOT HOW
WHERE. FORGIVE ME HOME WIRED I
MEAN WE LIVE TO KEEP OUR
CUSTOMERS ENGAGED WE ARE
MANDATE MANAGED OUR PERFORMANCE
METRICS THAT HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE AND SHOW HOW WELL
WE ARE KEEPING OUR CUSTOMERS
ENERGIZED. SO I THINK THIS KIND
OF- OF DISCUSSION IS HELPFUL
AND I ALSO WANT TO REITERATE
OUR COMMITMENT. TO CONTINUE TO
DO BETTER DO YOU USE THE S. P.
S. LAST TO DO IT BETTER WHEN WE
HAVE TO DO IT TO MAKE IT LESS
PAINFUL FOR CUSTOMERS WHEN IT
HAS TO HAPPEN. AND ALSO TO BE
MUCH MORE TRANSPARENT AND CLEAR
IN AND HOW AND WHY WE. ARE
EXECUTING YES YES. AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE I THINK THAT IS-
IS WHAT WE RECEIVE THAT IN THE
SPIRIT OF WHICH IS GIVEN AND
WE- LOOK FORWARD TO
COOPERATING- AND-
COLLABORATING- GOING FORWARD
AND I GUESS. YOU KNOW THE REAL.
THRUST BEHIND THE QUESTION WAS
WHAT HAPPENS. AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR AND WE FIND THAT-
THERE IS A- DEFICIENCY- AND
I'LL I'LL JUST- NOT NECESSARILY
FORCE YOU TO ANSWER THAT PART
OF IT AND WENT IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE SHOULD DO BUT I THINK. THE
IDEA OF. RECOGNIZING THAT AS
THE YEAR BECAUSE THIS YEAR GOES
FORWARD AND AS WE MOVE INTO THE
FUTURE YEARS WE DO WANT TO SEE-
NOT JUST INCREMENTAL INCREASES
IN EFFICIENCY AND- AN
EMPLOYMENT TATIAN OF WHAT
YOU'VE LAID OUT. BUT WE WANT TO
SEE QUICK- EFFICIENT MARKET.
IMPROVEMENT SO THAT WE ARE
GOING TO THEN LOOK TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE-
EARLIER ON THAT WE CAN START TO
MOVE AWAY FROM. THE
INTERNALIZATION AS A TECHNIQUE
THAT WE ARE NOW ACTIVELY SEEING
RESULTS. AND THAT TECHNOLOGY
AND OTHER. IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE BEING PROPERLY EXECUTED.
AND SO THEREFORE AS WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO HOLD ALL OF YOU TO
THE- TO THE- THE GOAL. THAT DE
ENERGIZING LINES BECOME
SOMETHING THAT. NOT ONLY DO IT
WHEN NECESSARY AND JUST IN
PARTICULAR INSTANCES BUT IT
BECOMES NOT NECESSAY AT ALL.
LET ME DISCUSSES THE QUESTION
TO SEE IF YOU SEE AND THEN I'M
GOING TO TURN TO OTHER MEMBERS-
AND I KNOW THE DOCTOR QUIRKIER
ON THE LINE I RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU. PUT YOUR- IMAGINARY HAND
UP- SO WE'LL- WILL RECOGNIZE
YOU AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO
MEMBERS HERE IN THE IN THE
CHAMBER- BUT LET ME ASK-
BECAUSE ABOUT YOU AND YOUR
TEAM- WHAT CAN BE DONE IN THE
MIDDLE OF FIRE SEASON. WHEN PS
PS EVENTS ARE ONGOING AND WE
SEE THAT A UTILITY IS FAILING
TO MEET CUSTOMER AND PUBLIC
SAFETY NEEDS DURING P. S. P. S.
OF A- SURE HOLDEN THANK YOU- I
WOULD SAY WE DOUBLE DOWN- WE%
DOUBLE DOWN IN TERMS OF OUR
OVERSIGHT OF THE UTILITY- AND
HOW WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE THAT
WE- HAVE SOME OF OUR-
ENFORCEMENT AND- MITIGATION
EMPLOYEES THEY'RE AT IN THEIR
CENTERS. IN THEIR MARGINS ARE
FOR EXAMPLE- WE HAVE DONE THAT
IN THE PAST WHERE WE HAVE-
BEEN- INVOLVED AT THE TIME OF
THE EVENT IN THEIR EMERGENCY
CENTERS I THINK WE WOULD-
ENGAGE IN THEM- NOT I THINK WE
WOULD. ENGAGE WITH THEM AT
EVERY LEVEL OF THE IPO YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY AREN'T
HEARING ONE TO THE PS PS
GUIDELINES. THAT THE P. YOU SEE
HAS PASSED AND- INSURING THAT
THEIR- DEFINITELY- BEING AT IT
HERE TOO I WOULD ALSO AS I HAVE
IN THE PAST I WILL WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH MARK GHILARDUCCI
AND HIS TEAM AT- YES. A
CALLAWAY YES TO BE SURE THAT WE
ARE ALL GETTING THE KIND OF
INFORMATION WE NEED TO FOR
EXAMPLE DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIRE SEASON- DIRECTOR
GHILARDUCCI. AND I SHARED
INFORMATION THAT- WE WERE
GETTING THE KIND OF REPORTING-
SORRY EDISON SPECIFICALLY FROM
MEDICINE THAT WE NEEDED TO AND
WE DID A CORRECTIVE ACTION IF
YOU WILL RIGHT THEN AND THERE-
WE HAVE- I'VE CALLED MEETINGS
AS WE NOTED TODAY IT'S BEEN
NOTED ELSEWHERE- TO- QUESTION
THEM AND FOLLOW UP KIND OF
MEMOS AND- ENQUIRIES NOT ONLY
ACTION PLANS. BUT ALSO
PARTICULARLY IN THE MEDICAL
BASELINE BATTERY- PROGRAMS
WHERE I WOULD SAY THEY'RE ALL
IMPROVING BUT THEIR WOEFULLY
BEHIND AND THIS IS OF GREAT
CONCERN TO THE PC AND- I MUST
SAY THAT ALMOST EVERY PUBLIC
COMMENT WE HAVE. WE HAVE WELL
WE HAVE A P. C. MEETINGS-
CUSTOMERS TESTIFIED TO THE FACT
THAT THEY DESPERATELY NEED A
BACKUP BATTERY SO- IT'S WE HAVE
SEVERAL TOOLS AT OUR OUR- IN
OUR TOOL KIT IF YOU WILL THAT
WE CAN ENGAGE IN REAL TIME
DURING THE FIRE SEASON. AND
BOTH WITH OUR EMPLOYEES. BEING
INVENTED IN IN. THE EMERGENCY-OPERATIONS OF- THE I. O. USED
AS WELL AS IF YOU WILL THE
POWER OF THE REGULATOR. AND WE
WILL WE WILL USE THAT I HAVE
USED IT AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY IS GETTING
AHEAD OF IT BEFOREHAND. AND AS
AS I DISCUSSED AND- MY
COLLEAGUES DISCUSSED WE'RE
DOING THAT IN CASES WHERE WE
THINK THERE'S SOME REMEDIAL
WORK NEEDING TO BE DONE NOW TO
PREPARE FOR- TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WE'RE ENGAGING WITH EDISON- YOU
KNOW AND ABIDE BY- BY MONTHLY
EFFORT AND WE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THE ACTION PLAN THAT THEY
SUBMITTED. TO THE COMMISSION IN
FEBRUARY AS WELL AS A FOLLOW UP
MEETING WE HAD YESTERDAY THEY
ARE DEEDED HEARING TO THE
ACTUAL LAN SO AS I'VE SAID
MANY TIMES I SAID TODAY MY
TESTIMONY. OUTCOMES THEY WILL
BE JUDGED BY THEIR OUTCOMES NOT
BY THEIR PLANS- GONNA DO TRYING
TO DO WILL DO SORT OF PLANNING.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE IN THE PRIOR
SEASON IS WE'VE ALL DISCUSSED
IS SHORTER IS LONGER AND WILL
BECOME. COME UPON US SOONER IT
WILL LAST LONGER AS WE
WITNESSED IN. AND WILL BE SOME
MORE SEVERE SO THAT PLANNING
MUST BE DONE NOW SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO DO CORRECTIVE ACTIONS
IN THE MIDST OF. LITERALLY THE
FIRESTORM. I HOPE THAT ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION SHAREHOLDER.
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER THANK
YOU PRESIDENT VENTURE- WE'RE
GOING TO TURN TO DR QUIRKY HAS
A QUESTION THEN. MISS RAYOS.
AND MISTER MASON THAT ORDER.
THANK YOU CHAIR. SO THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR THE UTILITY. TALK
ABOUT TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS-
DISCONNECTING THE FLOW OF
ELECTRONS THROUGH THE WINDS.
MORE WHEN THESE MEN WILL BERATE.
THAT ANOTHER CHECK NOW HELLO
WILL IT TAKE TO DEVELOP. FOR
THEM AND WHAT SORT OF
TECHNOLOGIES ALL YOU SEE IS
WHAT SORT OF A TIME FRAME. IN
NO. WHICH YOU TELL WITH A LOT
OF PEOPLE BIRDS. HI THIS IS A
JOHN JENKINS FROM SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC ALL ALL OF ALL STEP IN
PERSON- WE ARE APPOINTED I
BELIEVE YOUR PRINTER POLLING
CONDUCTED KNOWLEDGE EACH WERE
AT THE BILL THE ONE BREAKS IT
WE CAN SENSE THAT ENERGIZED FOR
HIS THE GROUND- WE DEPLOYED
THAT ON I BELIEVE EIGHT TO TEN
CIRCUIT TO. GET THE EXACT
NUMBER SOMEWHERE IN THAT RANGE
THOUGH AND- THE- IMPEDIMENT TO
GOING FASTER IS THE POINT OUR
PRIVATE LTE NETWORKS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A CERTAIN.
COMMUNICATION SPEED BETWEEN
DEVICES OBVIOUSLY IN ORDER FOR
THAT TO HAPPEN- WE PURCHASED
THE BROADBAND SPECTRUM FOR
PRIVATE LTE NETWORK LAST YEAR-
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
INSTALLING THE COMMUTER
STATIONS THE THAT'LL COST TO DO
THAT- BUT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
FULLY FUNCTIONAL BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND WE'VE BEEN INSTALLING THE
DEVICES THAT GO ALONG WITH THAT
TO TALK TO IT- WITH HER BY HER
NEED EFFORT SO IT'S. BEING DONE
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THAT. THE
AMAZING COMPETING I CAN GO NEXT
THANK SO MUCH FOR QUESTION- IN
ADDITION TO THE OTHER FALLING
CONDUCTOR KNOWLEDGE SAID THANK
YOU BROKE OFF. WHICH I
REFERENCED PREVIOUSLY THE
RAPTORS FONG AND THEIR TAKE ALL.
THANK IT THAT THAT HAS. AROUND
SINCE TO. INSTEAD OF VICTORIA
IN AUSTRALIA- ACTUALLY WHERE-
WE GOT INSIGHTS ON THE FOURTH
OF THE DAY THAT WOULD BE THE
BENCHMARKING BACK IN MIDDLE ONE
NINETEEN- SO I MENTIONED WE'VE
FIVE SOLD ON WATER CIRCUIT STOP
ACTING. ROUGHLY HUNDRED FIFTY
PLUS MILES HI AND. WE'RE
REALLY- EVALUATING. ALL COSTS.
OF UNDERMINED OF THAT ON OUR-
MORNING THAT PROCESS AND THAT'S
PART OF. ALSO LEARN. A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT IN TERMS OF
THE NATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES ALL YOU HAVE TO MAKE.
AND WE LOOK AT THIS TECHNOLOGY
HAS BEEN DEVELOPED WHO WITHIN
OUR OVERALL SYSTEM HARDENING.
IT'S NOT HAD A SKI- BUT BUT IT
DOES GO AFTER ONE OF THE
PRIMARY TYPES OF FALLS THAT
COULD RESULT IN A POTENTIALLY
MISSION- WHICH IS BASED GROUND
BALL- NOW WITH OTHER AREA THAT
DAY DOES NOT REALLY AFFECT ME
THEY GAVE YAK WHOSE. OUT YOU
SEE TWO LINES ARE SLAPPING
TOGETHER OR SOMETHING CALLED A
BASED BASEBALL. OUT WAR WHEN
YOU HAVE A TREE BRANCH THAT
MAYBE LAYING ON TOP OF THE TWO
FACES OF THE LINE SOMETHING
CALLED A HIGH IMPEDANCE FALL.
ALSO WE LOOK AT THIS AS ANOTHER
TOOL IN OUR TOOL KIT FIVE THIS
COUPLED WITH AUSTIN PARDONING
PROGRAM OF COVERED DOCTOR CAN
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE. RISK
PROFILE NOW WE'VE GOT A FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF MILES
WITH IPHONES BUT DISTRIBUTION
FROM FIVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU KNOW.
FIVE YEARS PLUS ON ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY- TECHNOLOGY THAT-
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IS-
SOMETHING CALLED THE
DISTRIBUTION TRANSMISSION
SUBSTATION FIRE ACTION SCHEME.
ALREADY USING A SERIES OF
CAMERAS AND SENSORS ARE MOUNTED
ON OUR EQUIPMENT TO QUICKLY
DETECT OBJECTS THAT ARE
APPROACHING. ENERGIZED POWER
LINES AND WE CAN DO THE
SHOPPING FOR THE AUTO OBJECT
ACTUALLY ENDS UP IMPACTING. THE
OVERHEAD LINE INCLUDING A
POTENTIAL SPARKED ACTION BY THE
PATENT HOLDERS- DECEMBER OF
LAST YEAR. YEAH WE DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER WAY TO GOT A WHOLE LOT
TRANSMISSION LINE. OF SEVENTY
MILES THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE-
THE POINT IS OPERATIONALLY- FOR
THIS YEAR AND THAT AS WE ARE.
OKAY THE SUCCESSFUL WE
ANTICIPATE I THINK WE CANNOT
QUICKLY ASKING A LOT THAT
IMPLEMENTATION GOING. TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. MARTIN'S BURKE.
YEAH USE OUR PUBLIC. YES YES
OUR- WHILE DOZENS LIKE IT THE
END OF THE NAY MORE THANK BOB
CHECKING. THAT YOU PEOPLE THAT.
ON THE WAYS IN WHICH- MARCH
TWENTY MORMON WE WILL BE WITH
MY TECHNOLOGY. SO PERHAPS I CAN
JUMP AND I THINK THAT RIGHT WE-
PILINGS MAYBE I CAN OUT THE
COMMITTEE ALSO IS- ACTIVELY
CALL. WITH A SENIOR MY P.
THAT'S OF OUR- WE ACTUALLY BEEN
DOING THAT FOR YEARS NOW- ALONG
WITH WORK WITH THE UTILITIES
ARE THE GLOBE SEARCHES ARE. WE
DO WORK. A RAPPER TALK LIMITING
WHICH IT DOES AN IMPORTANT TECH
THIS YEAR- AND SO WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD WITH- WITH THE TEST OF
THAT PROGRAMS LIKE TO THREE
DIFFERENT VARIETIES- WERE. I
WOULD EACH ONE OF THEM. ANOTHER
TECHNO YOU. FEEL A LITTLE BIT
PILOT- DISTRIBUTION BALTIC
DISSIPATION. SO THIS IS
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
WINTERKORN'S WITHIN THE LINE
AND IDENTIFYING PROBLEMS BEFORE
THE BAKER. JOHN MENTIONED-
DETECTING- ALL FALLING LINE
THIS IS A- PRE FILING LINE IF
YOU WILL- YOU IDENTIFY THINGS
LIKE. YOUR MICRO. PATTERNS IN
THE IN THE- SINGLES COMING YOUR
CIRCUITS. AND CAN GO OUT AND
INVESTIGATE AND WE'VE ACTUALLY
FOUND EVIDENCE OF. LINES ALLOW.
HAVING OCCURRED THAT WE WOULD
NEVER SEE IT DOESN'T RISE TO
FAULT IT DOESN'T RISE TO BOOK-
SPARKING YET- PUT IT IN THE
NEXT. TO DO THAT WE- WERE
TARGETING AROUND A HUNDRED THIS
YEAR WE'VE GOT IN ON SIXTY
CIRCUITS AND BY THE WAY WE HAVE
AROUND ELEVEN HUNDRED CIRCUITS.
DISTRIBUTION IN OUR CHOIR SIX
NOT INSIGNIFICANT. THE OTHER IS
EARLY FALL DETECTION REPAIR
WELL WHICH IS TO BE FAULTED
DISSIPATION THIS ACTUALLY USES
RADIO WAVES. AND SENSES OTHER
TYPES OF FAULTS BUT HE GIVES
YOU A BETTER IDEA OF WHERE CALL
MAYBE. I THINK FOR US AND AS IT
RELATES TO PS PS AND OVERALL
MITIGATIONS- D. B. CONCEPT IS.
IS MANY OVERLAPPING TOOLS TO
PROTECT AND MINIMIZE THE THREAT
OF A FIRE. IS THE PATH TO
ELIMINATING PS PS IT PROBABLY.
I'M LIKELY TO BE ANY ONE OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES- AND BY THE
WAY MACHINE LEARNING AND ALL
THAT IS BEING APPLIED TO. ALL
THE SIGNATURES WERE GETTING
FROM- THESE NEW INSTRUMENTS AND
NEW TECHNOLOGIES OUT WHICH WILL
HELP US BE. REALLY ABLE TO
PROTECT WORKERS A KIRK- HAVE
YOU HAVE IT OKAY FOR US IN BOTH
THE NORMAL HEART MEDICATION
PLAN. AND OVERALL GREAT PLAN IN
THE YEARS TO COME. BUT IT'S
WILL BE YEAR ON YEAR WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS- THEY'RE- PROBABLY.
PROBABLY WE DON'T SEE A SILVER
BULLET. HE HAD TO ELIMINATE THE
SPLC'S WANNABE ARTWORK. LOTS OF
IT AND ANY COUPLE. AN OVERLAP
TECHNO WILL GET THERE. GIVEN
ALL THE TECHNOLOGY WALLS WELL.
I'M AS THE OF YES YES STATE ALL.
YES I'M GONNA GO. CONCERT I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR IT- THE-
WITH ALL THE CHECK THAT NEED TO
BE DEVELOPED AND- I WOULD THAT.
YES YES IT NEEDS TO ALL. IT IT
WILL BE SO I TAKE YOUR A YEAR
BUT I DO THINK YOU'RE ON YOUR
WRIST SIGNIFICANT- AS WE-
CONTINUE A LIMITED SOURCES OF
NATION'S AND EVERYTHING OUR ADD-
IS YOU KNOW IN THE THEY-
DEVELOPMENT OUT OF CLAY IT'S
WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON. YES YES
SO I REALLY WANT TO ON THE I
THINK WILL SEE. PROGRESS
TOWARDS REDUCTIONS IN P. S. B.
S. OVER THE EARLY YEARS AND SO
I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
REALLY FOCUSED AND- AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN AS EFFICIENTLY AS WE
CAN REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF P.
S. B. S. THAT WE THINK WE NEED
TO- TO PERFORM. IT'S VERY HARD
TO GET LOANS YEAH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK GOD THAT'S-
PRESERVER MISTER BASS. STIR
CHAIR- I'M GLAD WE'RE HERE-
GLAD THAT WE PUT THIS TOGETHER
YOU KNOW AS- ONE OF THE ROLES
THAT WE HAVE AS MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS NOT IN COMMITTEE
IS OVERSIGHT AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
DO JUST THAT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT HELLO THE ONE
THING I'M ALWAYS. A BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT IS OF THE WAY
AS POLITICIANS THAT WE
SOMETIMES BEHAVE- BECAUSE- AS
POLITICIANS WE REFLECTED WE
REACT TO OUR CONSTITUENCIES AND
I KNOW WITH THESE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS WE HAD A LOT OF FOLKS IN
OUR RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS THAT
WERE WERE UPSET OR ANGRY AND SO
AS THEIR ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES WE COME HERE-
WANTING TO SHOW US SOME OF THAT
ANGER AND BE ABLE TO TELL
PEOPLE WHO'S BOSS. THE ONE
THING OF COURSE- THAT COMES
WITH TIME BEING HERE IN THIS-
THIS BODY AND EXPERIENCES AND
THAT WE HAVE A WITHIN THIS BODY
IS UNDERSTANDING HOW WE GOT TO
THIS VERY PLACE- I WOULD JUST
THE OTHER EVENING I WAS
EXPLAINING TO ONE OF THE NEW
MEMBERS THIS YEAR THAT WHY WE
HAVE PS PS IN THE FIRST PLACE
AND WE HAVE P. S. P. S. BECAUSE
THIS LEGISLATURE TOLD- THE- THE
I'LL USE TO- TO HAVE PS PS
BECAUSE WE AS A LEGISLATURE
COULD NOT GET TO A PLACE. WHERE
WE COULD AMEND ARTICLE ONE
SECTION NINETEEN OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION THAT PROVIDES FOR-
AND THAT DOMAIN THE PAYMENT AND
DAMAGES AND OF COURSE ALL THAT
GOES WITH WE TALK ABOUT THE
DOCTOR OF INVERSE CONDEMNATION
THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE BECAUSE
OF THE LIABILITY OF THESE FIRES
WERE SO INCREDIBLE AND THE COST
WE'RE GOING TO BE SO GREAT AND
I KNOW THAT THAT THE CHAIR AND
I SERVED- ON THE SB NINE A ONE.
A ARE THE CONFERENCE- WE ALSO-
ENDED UP COMING UP WITH THE
ENORMOUS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
BUT IT SURE WAS THE- I WAS THE
LEAD AUTHOR ON ON AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR TO COME UP WITH A WILDFIRE
FUND THAT HAS. BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF CLAIMS PAYING
CAPACITY WHY BECAUSE THESE
FIRES THE COST OF THEM ARE
GREAT AND WE AS A LEGISLATURE
COULD NEVER GET TO THE FACT
THAT WE COULD. AMEND OR FIX
THAT SECTION OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION WE UNDERSTAND
THERE'S LIABILITY THAT'S THERE.
MY QUESTION IS THAT'S THE
STATEMENT THAT I WANT TO MAKE
IT A QUESTION THAT IWAS GOING
TO HAVE IS THE ONE THAT. A
DOCTOR CORK- ENDED UP ASKING
AND THAT IS. THAT THE GOAL
NEEDS TO BE TO BE ABLE TO LIMIT
THESE P. S. P. S. ADVANCE AS
MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
APPROVE. ON UP ON THE SYSTEM
AND WHEN THERE'S TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE. OF IT ARE WE AT THE
PLACE- TO BE ABLE TO GET TO
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE TO DE
ENERGIZE AND I THINK. THE
ANSWER WAS THERE AT LEAST BYE
BYE BYE ONE OF ONE OF THE FOLKS
SAYING THAT WITHIN THE NEXT.
TEN YEARS MAYBE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO SEE THEM BUT THE GOAL NEEDS
TO BE TO TRY TO LIMIT THEM. BUT
WE NEED TO BE WORKING TOGETHER
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A SYSTEM.
THAT WORKS AND WE JUST HAVE TO
BE VERY CAUTIOUS AND VERY
CAREFUL. THAT WE DON'T START
BRINGING UP A LOT OF THIS A
NEGATIVE RHETORIC TO GET PEOPLE
ALL FIRED UP. ONCE AGAIN WE'VE
DONE AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
WORK IN. THIS SPACE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU POINT.
WEL TAKEN BUT I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT.
THERE'S CERTAIN DEFICIENCIES
AND EX AND IMPLEMENTING. THE
GUIDELINES IN OR YOU CAN SAY
HERE'S WHAT WE EXPECT YOU TO DO
AND IT'S LIKE OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO DO IT AND THEN IT DOESN'T
GET DONE. I THINK EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS DE ENERGIZING LINES
TECHNOLOGY IT ALL GOES HAND IN
HAND. THE UNDERGROUND IN THE
LINES FOR WINDOW VENTS IS ALSO
ANOTHER DETERRENT SO THERE'S A
LOT OF THERE'S A MENU. OF
THINGS THAT WERE OUTLINED IN
NINE OH ONE. AND WHAT'S
EXPECTED IN THESE MITIGATION
PLANS AND THE P. U. C. HAS
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY. TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE PLANS ARE BEING
MONITORED AND IT HERE TO AND
WHAT WE'RE SEEING.IS THAT NOT
THE SAME KIND OF EFFORT. YOU
KNOW THERE THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION THAT NOT
WITHSTANDING. THE CHALLENGES
THAT THIS COMES WITH- THAT. YOU
STILL HAVE TO STEP UP. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE OF THIS
OVERSIGHT IS TO SORT OF. NO PUN
INTENDED KEEP THE FIRE LIT-
RECORD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
INFORMATIVE HEARING I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THAT WILDFIRE
IS ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS WORRY ABOUT MOST
IS WHAT KEEPS THEM UP AT NIGHT
I REPRESENT COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE ON THE WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY
AND THEY'RE AFRAID THEY'RE
AFRAID OF UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES. AND THEN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WHO WE WERE DEVASTATED
BY THE PS PS EVENTS THAT WERE
SO POORLY MANAGED WE WERE OUT
FOR ALMOST A WEEK IN SOME
INSTANCES WITH LITTLE TO NO
COMMUNICATION HOSPITALS WERE
TOLD THEY WOULDN'T BE TURNED UP
DE ENERGIZED AND THEY WERE DE
ENERGIZED WITH NO NOTICE- I
THINK THAT I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE DIRECTORS AND
PRESIDENT BADGER FOR
HIGHLIGHTING. THE DANGER OF
THESE EVENTS I THINK THAT IS
WHAT GOES UNMENTIONED SO
FREQUENTLY WE TALK ABOUT THE
NEED TO HAVE THESE EVENTS IN
ORDER TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY
BUT WE LOSE LIVES WHEN WE HAVE
THESE EVENTS AS WELL NUMBERS OF
SENIORS FELL DURING THE DAYS ON
AND P. S. P. S. EVENTS THAT LED
TO THEIR DEATHS. AND I THINK
THAT NEEDS TO BE MENTIONED
BECAUSE THESE ARE NOT INCIDENTS
THAT ARE WITHOUT HORRIBLE
OUTCOMES AND SO WE NEED TO BE
AS CAREFUL AS WE CAN AND HOW WE
USE THEM HOW LONG THEY LAST AND
HOW THEY'RE IMPLEMENTED. I DO
ALSO WANT TO CREDIT PRESIDENT
BADGER THE DIRECTORS AND PG&E
FOR A VAST IMPROVEMENT YEAR
OVER YEAR BETWEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY AS
REFLECTED IN THE NUMBERS THAT
WERE PRESENTED TODAY WE SAW
INCREDIBLE DECREASE IN THE
IMPACT OF PS PS THIS YEAR I
HEARD FROM NONE OF MY HOSPITALS
THIS YEAR THAT THEY WERE DE
ENERGIZED WITH NO NOTICE SO
THAT WAS GREAT NEWS FOR ME-
AND- YOU KNOW. IT WAS DONE IN A
WAY THAT WAS BETTER WE HAVE A
LOT OF WAYS TO GO BUT I DO WANT
TO CREDIT THE VAST IMPROVEMENT
IN JUST A. SINGLE YEAR TO THE
IMPACT OF THESE EVENTS. I'M
MIKE QUESTION FOR. DIRECTOR
THOMAS JACOBS IS THAT YOU
MENTIONED THAT IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY ONE REPORTS THAT
WAS. PUT FORWARD JUST RECENTLY
PG&E SAID THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THE PROJECTIONS WERE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FOR THE PS PS EVENTS
OR THEY WERE. UNDETERMINED CAN
YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT IS THAT AGAIN WE
EXPECT CONTINUED IMPROVEMENT
AND I WOULD EXPECT TO
PROJECTION TO SHOW THAT. BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE THAT IS AND WHAT
WAS IN THE REPORT. SURE I CAN
BE THAT SO THE REPORT THAT WE
REQUIRE THEM TO SUBMIT
PROJECTIONS FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PERFORMANCE METRICS- PG&E DID
SUPPLY SOME OF THOSE. SOME OF
THEM THEY SAID THEY COULD NOT
SUPPLY YET BECAUSE THERE IS
GOOD CURRENT- A PROPOSED
CONDITIONS THROUGH THE FEDERAL
COURT. THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY
IMPACT THE NUMBER OF PS PS
EVENTS AND THE SCOPE OF THOSE
EVENTS. BASED ON THE OUTCOME OF
THAT SO THEY DID NOT INCLUDE
THAT PRODUCTION AND THEN WHEN
THAT IS SETTLED THEY WILL THEY
HAVE COMMITTED ALREADY TO ME
THEY WILL SUBMIT THAN THEIR
PROJECTIONS ONCE THEY HAVE
THAT. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR ENSURING THAT WE WILL GET
THOSE PROJECTIONS BECAUSE I
THINK I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
POINT ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
WATCH. YOUR OVER YOUR THE
IMPROVEMENT BUT WE CAN ONLY DO
THAT IF WE HAVE LAST YEAR'S
DATA PROJECTIONS AND HOW THEY
PERFORM AGAINST THOSE
PROJECTIONS. AND I ALSO HAD A
QUESTION SIMILAR TO WHAT DOCTOR
FORECAST ABOUT HOW- I
APPRECIATE THE GOAL BEING.
GETTING TO A PLACE WHERE WE NO
LONGER NEED THESE PSCS EVENTS
AND THAT PEOPLE. THAT WE ARE A
LOT WE ARE ABLE TO RELIABLY AND
SAFELY PROVIDE ENERGY TO OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH SHOULD BE THE
EXPECTATION THAT I THINK ALL OF
US SHOULD HAVE FOR I'LL USE-
AND I APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS
ABOUT TECHNOLOGY MY QUESTION
FOR- THE FOLKS AT THE P. YOU
SEE WHOEVER WANTS TO ANSWER
THIS AND ALSO. THE I USE IF
THEY SO DESIRE IS. HOW ARE WE
SORT OF IN ANSWERING DOCTOR HER
QUESTION THERE WAS A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO SCOTT IF THEY'RE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES OBVIOUSLY
HARDENING THE GRID. MAINTENANCE
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE ALWAYS
TO GET TO A SAFER GRADE THAT
WOULDN'T REQUIRE. AN D.
ENERGIES ASIAN HOW ARE WE
TRACKING THAT- I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IMPROVEMENT BUT
HOW ARE WE SORT OF SETTING A
GOAL TO. KNOW. D. ENERGIES
ATION AND GETTING THEIR- WELL.
THANK VERY- YEAH- I AM GOING TO
ADD CAROLINE TO TALK ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE IT FITS WELL INTO THE
WELFARE MITIGATION PLANS AND-
STRATEGIES AND THEN METRICS
THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED TO HOLD
FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS OTHER
STRATEGIES FOR THE PS PS
CAROLINE SURE SO THAT GOES TO
THE HEART OF HOW WE EVALUATE
THE WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS
AND WHAT WE ESTABLISHED LAST
YEAR WAS A VERY CLEAR STRUCTURE
ON. THE TYPE OF CONTENT NOT
WITH THE ACTUAL CONTENT IS
BECAUSE THE POLICE HAVE TELL US
WHAT THEIR PLAN IS BUT HOW THE
STRUCTURE THAT CONTENT SO THAT
WE CAN DIVE INTO THAT SO
SPECIFIC TO YOUR QUESTION IS
WE'VE CREATED TEN DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES THAT WE- OF REQUIRED
UTILITIES TO SUBMIT INFORMATION
AND A LOT OF INCLUDING THE
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES AND WE
HAVE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO
DO ANALYSIS ON THOSE SPECIFIC
AREAS. AND WE ASK THAT- REQUIRE
THE UTILITIES DISSIDENT
PERFORMANCE METRICS TO EACH OF
THOSE AREAS AND WE LOOK AT A
DIFFERENT SEVERAL DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PERFORMANCE METRICS
LEADING AND LAGGING INDICATORS
AS WELL AS THE OUTCOME METRICS
AND THEN THE UTILITIES ALSO
OFTEN INCLUDE THEIR PROGRAM
TARGETS FOR EXAMPLE HOW MANY
SEXUALIZING DEVICES ARE GOING
TO SIT- I DO THIS YEAR OR HOW
MANY TREES ARE GONNA EXPECT
THAT TYPE OF THING. ARE THEN
TEAM LOOKS AT ALL OF THAT AND
WE PUT PUSH IN ON EACH OF THOSE
IN OUR ANALYSIS AND I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT
DECIDING WHICH TOOLS THEY'RE
GOING TO USE TO TRY AND REDUCE
THE RISK. EACH UTILITY HAS
DIFFERENT TOPOGRAPHY HAVE
DIFFERENT CUSTOMER BASE
DIFFERENT GREAT DESIGN THAT FOR
THEIR JOB WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE PROBING ON THE QUESTIONS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
THINKING THROUGH THAT AND
SPECIFICALLY ON THE EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES WE ALSO OFTEN ASK
IS THAT YOU UTILITIES A
REFERENCE ALREADY ALREADY
COORDINATING WITH EACH OTHER SO
THAT THEY'RE LEARNING FROM EACH
OTHER. ON THE DIFFERENT PILOTS
THEY'RE DOING AND THEN
LEVERAGING WHERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE ON THEIR BREAD THE-
THOSE LEARNINGS AND NOT EVERY.
SINGLE DAY A PILOT CAN BE
PICKED UP AND DROPPED INTO
ELSE'S TERRITORY. BUT WE MAKING
SURE THAT THE CONGRESS ARE.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO LEVERAGE.
THE EXTENT. OF GETTING IN FOR
OUT THERE SO THEY DON'T ALL
HAVE TO REPEAT THE SAME
THAILAND. THEY DON'T ALL HAVE
TO THINK THROUGH THESE THINGS
INDIVIDUALLY BECAUSE TO THE
POINT- THAT WAS EARLIER BROUGHT
UP BY THE COMMITTEE. NUMBER WE
WANT THIS TO HAPPEN IN A VERY
EFFICIENT AND FAST WAY TO BE
ABLE TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR PS
PS. THANK YOU ARE THERE
SPECIFIC I KNOW LAST YEAR I
THINK WE HAD MET AND YOU HAD
SAID THAT YOU WERE TRYING TO
REDUCE B. S. B. S. EVENTS BY
THIRTY PERCENT. FROM TWENTY-
NINETEEN ARE THERE SPECIFIC
METRICS THAT THE AYE USER
TRYING TO MEET YOUR EVERY YEAR.
SO 30% WAS ACTUALLY TEACHING
HE'S AFTER OKAY YOU DON'T SET
THAT GOAL. BUT WE ASK THEM TO
SET THEIR GOALS BASED ON HOW
THEY'RE APPLYING THEIR
MITIGATION STRATEGIES. AND THEY
TELL US WHAT THEIR GOAL IS AND
THEN WE POTENTIALLY PUSH ON
THAT GOAL. BUT THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT PROPOSALS. I THINK YOU'RE
PROCEEDING FROM. THANK YOU I
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS HERE ON
THE COMMITTEE. IN THE CHAMBER
WHO ARE SEEKING. A RECOGNITION
FOR ASKING A QUESTION IS THERE
ANYONE. ON THE LINE. SAM NUNN-
THEN AS WE MOVE TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT- I'D LIKE TO. RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT'S WHERE WE ARE ON THE
AGENDA AT THIS MOMENT AND I'M-
ONE OF THE STATE THAT WILL
MAINTAIN- DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING. AS IS CUSTOMARY IN AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE CHAMBER
OR- REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVING THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
DO WE HAVE- LET'S SEE. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE WHOWOULD LIKE TO
COMMA OF IN FROM THE BACK OF
THE GALLERY. THERE'S ONE PERSON.
I AM SO PLEASED TO STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST BURNING A
ROSTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME BRIEF
COMMENTS- FIRST OF ALL THE
CABLE INDUSTRY WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMISSION AND THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES- IN
THEIR EFFORTS TO. ENSURE THAT-
IN DEVELOPING THESE GUIDELINES
FOR PS PS IS THERE'S THERE IS
NO COMPROMISE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND PUBLIC SAFETY STANDARDS OR
GOALS SO WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
THAT- MR HOLDEN ARCHER HOLDEN I
WANT TO. TOUCH ON SOMETHING YOU
SAID EVERYONE WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY AS A ROLE HERE
AND- RECENTLY A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO THE COMMISSION JUST
RECENTLY ADOPTED- NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR COMMUNICATION
SERVICE PROVIDERS OF SEVEN TWO
HOURS OF BACKUP POWER. AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE
FOR US- THAT'S WE HAVE OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND NOTES IN
CALIFORNIA EACH OF THOSE NOTES
IS GOING TO REQUIRE A BACKUP
GENERATORS SELL WHEAT IN THEIR
HAVE CELLS WE HAVE BATTERIES
NOW THAT PROVIDES YOU KNOW
ROUGHLY- TWELVE FIFTEEN HOURS
OF BACKUP POWER BUT SEVEN TWO
HOURS IS A CHALLENGE. SO THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF TIME AND
EFFORT IS A LOT OF MONEY AND WE
ARE COMMITTED TO DOING THAT-
THE COMMISSION DD PROVIDE FOR
A WAIVER PROCESS IN THE EVENT
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE. SOME
CHALLENGES IN GETTING THOSE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PERMITS SO IN
YOUR COMMENT ABOUT EVERYONE HAS
A ROLE HERE I MEAN WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BETTER PARTNER WITH
COMMUNICATION SERVER SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN GETTING THOSE
PERMITS- THE- PERMIT PROCESS AT
THE COMMISSION HAS. IS VERY
CHALLENGING IT'S A EIGHT MONTH
WINDOW PERIOD THAT WE HAVE TO
GET THOSE BATTERIES IN PLACE
FOR THIS BACKUP POWER OR
WHATEVER WE NEED SO WE'RE
HOPING THAT- THERE CAN BE A
BETTER PARTNERSHIP ON THAT AND
THAT- AS YOU CONTINUE TO
MONITOR HOW THESE PS PIECE
EVENTS ARE. ROLLED OUT THAT WE
COME BACK AND REVISIT THIS OF
PERMITTING PROCESS FOR BACKUP
POWERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
WE'LL TAKE NOTE OF THOSE
COMMENTS ON THE INTO. THE ISSUE
AS YOU OUTLINED IT AND SEE IF
WE CAN GET SOME KIND OF SENSE
OF NEXT DIRECTION ON THAT I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. HI IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY NO ONE ELSE IN THE
GALLERY- THEN WHAT I'D LIKE TO
DO IS- MOVE WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IS THERE
ANYONE. THERE TO PEOPLE THAT
ARE- WAITING TO SPEAK.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. SO WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PRESS ONE ZERO AND
OUR FIRST PUBLIC COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE TWENTY TWO. HI
LINE TWENTY TWO AND MY AND
COMMITTEES. YES YOU ARE. MY
NAME IS ANDREA HAS FROM AND I'M
CALLING IN TODAY OF THE
DISPLACED PERSON FROM THE TUBBS
FIRE I AS A MEMBER OF A FAMILY
OF SIX PEOPLE INCLUDING FOUR
YOUNG CHILDREN WAS LIVING IN
SANTA ROSA IN OCTOBER OF
SEVENTEEN WHEN THE TUBBS FIRE
DESTROYED FIFTY THREE HUNDRED
HOMES AND LARGELY GOTTEN STATED
CINEMA COUNTY IN GENERAL A
DISASTER FROM WHICH THIS REGION
HAVE LARGELY NOT RECOVERED. SO
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT THIS TOPIC
IS OF PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE AND
INTERESTS TO ME WITH THE
SUCTION AND IMPORTANT AND
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THAT I HAVE
SPOKEN IN PERSON IN MULTIPLE
HEARING THERE IN THE CAPITAL
ABOUT FIVE YEARS UTILITIES AND
RELATED TOPICS. HOW MY YOUNG
CHILDREN SO I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
SOME INFORMATION ACCORDING TO A
JULY TENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ARTICLE BY BRANDON
REGIMEN WITH ABC TEN EIGHT OUT
OF TEN MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE ACCEPTED
CORPORATE FILING PG&E AND THIS
WAS AFTER PG&E DONATED MILLION
TO CALIFORNIA POLITICIAN AFTER
IT WAS CONVICTED OF SIX FEDERAL
FELONIES CONNECTED CONNECTED TO
THE TWO THOUSAND TEN SEVERAL
PIPELINE EXPLOSION THAT KILLED
EIGHT PEOPLE SIMILARLY
ACCORDING TO A WASHINGTON POST
ARTICLE FROM NOVEMBER ELEVEN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. NEWSOME
ACCUSE PG&E OF CORPORATE GREED
BUT OVER THE LAST FEW DECADES
ACCEPTED OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DONATIONS
FROM A CONVICTED FELON POWER
MONOPOLY PG&E TO FIND HIS
POLITICAL CAREER AND HIS WIFE
MOVIE COMPANY EXCUSE ME ABOUT
IT IS THAT A CONCERN. I DON'T
ME I DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT
YOU BUT THIS IS IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION THAT YOU'RE. GOING TO
GET INTO THAN THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. AND I WOULD DENIED
ACCESS TO THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
EVEN THE LAST WEEK I ATTENDED
AN ASSEMBLY SESSION IN PROGRESS
THAT. IS SHOCKING TO ME THAT IS
A DISPLACED PERSON FROM ONE OF
THE DEADLIEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES. IN
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE IMPROPERLY
HISTORY THAT I WOULD BE DENIED
ACCESS TODAY TO THE PEOPLE HOW
TO OUR HOUSE. TO MY CHILD. MY
QUIET YEAH AND- HEARING NOTHING.
NOTHING AND THEN DIDN'T ME VERY
CALL CAN- MA'AM HI. MA'AM I DO
A YOU HAVING YOUR OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE YOUR THOUGHTS- WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
CALLER BUT THANK YOU FOR- FOR
WAITING AROUND AND BEING ABLE
TO SHARE YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS
WITH THE COMMITTEE- MODERATOR
OUR OUR NEXT TO PUBLIC SPEAKER.
OUR NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JOHN KENNEDY AND
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE REPRESENT THIRTY SEVEN WORLD
COUNTIES AND THEY BORN THE
BRUNT OF RECENT WILDFIRES IN PF
YET THE BAND. ESPECIALLY MANY
COMMUNITIES THEY'VE EXPERIENCED
PROLONGED AND BACK TO BACK YES
THAT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT WE UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE WORLD UP HERE
YES THE BENCH PLAY IN REDUCING
THE RISK UTILITY CAUSED
WILDFIRE CONDITIONS. HOWEVER
WERE ALSO ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY COST THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FIRST
RESPONDERS AND RESIDENTS
ESPECIALLY AT TIMES WHEN
WILDFIRES IS ALREADY HIGH
BRITISH SPEAKING STRONGLY
ADVOCATE FOR REDUCING THE SIZE
SCOPE FREQUENCY AND DURATION OF
FUTURE P. S. P. S. ANAND SAYS
YOU GUYS HAVE. TALKED ABOUT
TODAY IT'S FRUSTRATING TO KNOW
THAT IN CALIFORNIA HOME TO
SILICON VALLEY AND
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUES FOR THE
STAR POWER IN PS PS ADAMS.
ASSEMBLY PROBLEM WHEN THOSE
POWER OUTAGES RESULTING MARC
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE IN THE
ABILITY OF FIRST RSPONDERS TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES IN FOR
THOSE REASONS WE DID STRONGLY
SUPPORT RECENT CPUC
COMMUNICATIONS RESILIENCY
STANDARDS TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS DURING A
POWER OUTAGE. WITH KNOWLEDGE
UTILITIES HAVE UNDERTAKEN
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS
IMPACTED MITIGATE IMPACTS
CRITICAL FACILITIES AND IMPROVE
INTERACTIONS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AT THE SAME TIME
MUCH WORK REMAINS TO BE DONE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE CPUC AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO REFINE. THE PFAS
GUIDELINES AND REDUCE THE SIZE
SCOPE FREQUENCY AND DURATION OF
OFFENSE AND MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS OF THAT IMPACT BOTH THE
BANDS FOR CRITICAL FACILITIES
INSTANCE THE POPULATIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS TODAY.
THANK YOU WE. APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS- MY IS THERE OTHER.
PERSON OR ANYONE ELSE A IS
WHERE ON LINE. WE ONE MORE COME
FROM LINE TWENTY FIVE WE'VE
AHEAD. SURE HOLD NUMBER THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS WE'RE BACK
AND WE- OF R. G. THANK YOU AND
TO YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF TODAY
FOR THIS IMPORTANT CARING AND
FRIENDLY ENERGY IS THE PARENT
COMPANY OF GOLD ZERO WHICH
MAKES THE YETI PORTABLE POWER
STATION THESE ARE THEIR
PORTABLE LITHIUM ION BATTERY
CAPABLE OF POWERING COMMON
HOUSEHOLD APPLIANCES AND
MEDICAL DEVICES. THEY GET THE
BATTERIES HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED TO
DATE NOT JUST BY THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES BUT ALSO THEY
HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED BY PHONE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATORS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO HELP MITIGATE
THE IMPACT OF YEAH YEAH-
WONDERFUL CUSTOMERS WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE ATTORNEY I'LL
USE FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP IN
THIS ON GOING EFFORT AND WE ARE
AVAILABLE TO BE A RESOURCE TO
YOU ALL. AND THE ONGOING
DISCUSSION TO IMPROVE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE AT THE STATE
CONTINUES TO TACKLE OUR CLIMBED
AND WILDFIRE RESILIENCY EFFORTS
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTRIBUTION TO THE DISCUSSION
TODAY AND YOU'RE YOU'RE SHARING
YOUR THOUGHTS. OCT MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE WE HAVE
HEARD. FROM ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. SHARE A LADY THE
GENTLEMEN ONCE A IF YOU WOULD
LIKE. PROVIDE PUBLIC. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND. ZERO IN MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO- FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
AS MODERATOR HAVING HEARD ALL
PUBLIC TESTIMONY MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SEEING NONE A LET
ME JUST CONCLUDE BY SAYING I
WANT TO THANK THE PANELISTS FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY AND
PARTICIPATION TODAY- I THINK
IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT. IT'S
BEEN- IMPORTANT SUBJECT- TO- TO
FOCUS IN ON AND CERTAINLY AS OF
LAST YEAR IT WAS- INCREDIBLY-
INTENSE- ISSUE- I LET ME JUST
SAY I THOUGHT THAT THE
UTILITIES LEARNED FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN EVENTS ON
WHAT NOT TO DO. THE CPUC
APPEARS TO HAVE REALLY STEPPED
UP ITS EFFORTS TO PROTECT
CUSTOMERS BY ADOPTING EXTENSIVE
PROTOCOLS TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF P. S. P. S. AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. IN LIGHT OF THEIR
EFFORTS HI HELD SEVERAL BILLS
ON THE TOPIC IN THE COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR. IT IS NOW INCUMBENT
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
ESPECIALLY MISS HERE TO TAKE
THE LESSONS SHARED AT TODAY'S
HEARING AND TO LOOK AT THE
PERFORMANCE OUTLINED. AND TO
SEE WHERE WE GO FROM HERE. I
LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE'VE
CONCLUDED THIS AGENDA AND AGAIN
TO OUR PANELISTS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION COOPERATION
AND YOUR INSIGHT. HAS BEEN VERY
INSTRUCTIVE- TO HELP US IN
TERMS OF. FROM HERE. ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE HìNH UTILITIES AND
ENERGY IS A GERMAN.